ah en passant
chaise.com/evensko tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentiels
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes-rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts
et même vos personnalités préférées du
monde des échecs émoticônes et les
emojis disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coûts et les animations spéciales
restent sur les chéquier jusqu'à ce
qu'elles soient effacées pour ce faire
il suffit de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'emoji ou de
cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
vous voulez streamer des échecs comme
vos créateurs préférés tels que
blindstream Naka ou les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
Chess.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience en connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors d'autres
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à cheese.com/
settings/connecting tiret eucons mettre
échec comme catégorie sur twitch et
commencer à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaître et dans notre
liste de streamers en direct votre
profites.com affichera votre stream
twitch qui sera aussi mis en avant
durant vos parties offert utiliser la
commande community streamer dans le chat
et faites grossir votre audience sans
plus attendre
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
stream de Chris comfr avec ici un
nouveau match so Wesley contre aronyan
qui va commencer ici quelques minutes
normalement à 20h pile on va commencer
ce match donc je vous rappelle un petit
peu comment ça se passe on va avoir
trois segments premier segment 1h30 de 5
+ 1 ensuite une heure de trois plus une
et pour finir une demi-heure de une plus
une donc c'est c'est hyper hyper chaud
hier on a eu le match de youngui contre
Nakamura qui s'amusait à bouger tous les
pions d'une case il a commencé par A4
puis A3 puis B4 puis B3 puis etc il a
fait tous les petits pions
chaque coup de pion chaque ouverture
absolument qu'il avait les blancs il
s'est bien amusé là aujourd'hui on va
voir quand même deux joueurs qui sont
quand même plus sérieux et qui veulent
plus aux échecs donc on va voir je pense
des ouvertures quand même qui sont bien
plus classiques on va voir du E4 du D4
du C4 on va m'en voir des autres
normales
alors donc ça va commencer très bien tôt
je vais vous retrouver j'avais un petit
lien
sympa avec ici les
je vous rappelais les
prédictions qui avaient donné de
cheescom par rapport par rapport aux
joueurs alors je liens que je dois avoir
ici
je vais mettre sur l'autre onglet ouais
je l'ai ici voilà
et je vais vous montrer un petit peu
tout ça pour vous donner un petit peu
des idées de
des côtes que les joueurs ont
apparemment dans ce match alors dans ce
match
donc c'est ce contre Aronian à votre
avis dans le chat dites-moi un peu
est-ce que vous avez un favori est-ce
que vous pensez que
que enfin qu'est-ce que vous pensez en
tout cas des pourcentages des cotes de
chaque joueur dans ce match c'est le
sinbads c'est une vague qui est passé
sur Youtube et qui n'est plus sur twitch
aujourd'hui salut à toi j'espère que tu
vas bien en tout cas bonjour à tous ceux
qui nous qui nous rejoignent
sur le sur le live salut Robert je pense
au 140 pour sceau mais c'est chaud OK
alors c'est clair que c'est chaud c'est
que c'est chaud c'est un match hyper
compliqué
j'ai un petit doute une seconde
quitte avec ouais c'est bon
les gens n'ont pas commencé encore un
jeu je pense en tout cas moi chez moi ça
va pas commencer
et comme je le vois regarder
l'ordinateur je me dis peut-être ça a
commencé
j'espère que je suis pas en retard
une recommencer très bien
je vais actualiser peut-être que j'ai
pas
non chez moi
ça n'a pas commencé chez moi
et oui je suis sur twitch oui sur twitch
donc alors les pourcentages je les ai
ici je voulais donner donc ça commence
et les pourcentages
je vais reprendre mon petit fichier
pixel il donne 54% pour saut donc 46
pour un rognan et ils disent que le
match il peut il peut se terminer avec
14 et demi contre très ennemis c'est les
prédictions de cheesecom donc pour le
Blitz il donne quand même 5 4 en faveur
de aronyan en 5 + 1 c'est ce que nous
propose ici
comme fr enfin James comme international
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
j'ai l'impression que les gens sont en
train de jouer ils font une tête
le timer qui est
[Musique]
le timer qui a commencé chez moi et il
est parti qui s'affiche pas
pourquoi est-ce que les parties
s'affichent pas j'ai un problème les
gars j'ai un problème
mais le Timer est parti
je vais voir si on me parle
je vais essayer par un autre endroit je
vais passer par play
[Musique]
si il y a eu un problème
non non
aucun problème de signaler chez moi sur
cela
je vais du coup essayer de retrouver
c'était sensible bien se passer et là en
fait et ben j'ai les parties bon j'ai
rien fait j'ai rien fait ça c'est tout
seul je l'ai demandé j'ai pris à très
fort et c'est venu ok pour faire
rapidement
voilà donc ce Canet blanc dans la
première
avec Tom F3 grand rock cavaluation
en tout cas pour les deux joueurs c'est
extrêmement connu sous le 7 fous des
trois
OK et on en est ici et donc en fait bon
c'est une position qui est assez ouverte
ça c'est cool
et c'est des vrais échecs comparer un
petit peu à hier ce qu'on nous a fait
Nakamura qui était à la limite du
respect
aujourd'hui c'est quand même plus sympa
dans le sens où ça marche qui va quand
même être beaucoup plus équilibré et on
va voir aussi des vrais échecs des vrais
ouvertures là c'est une vraie ouverture
c'est la timonov donc G6 par les Blancs
donc pareil un petit peu là menace F5 et
comment est-ce que so peut continuer
alors je vous rappelle pour ceux qui ne
savent pas parce que j'ai commenté plein
de fois quand même so Wesley lors de
lors de d'événements donc
c'est vraiment il a une manière de jouer
qui a assez incroyable je parle pas de
la manière à laquelle il jouait l'échec
je parle
l'handicap qui se donne quand il joue
alors c'est assez bizarre parce que vous
savez on voit un rogner qui est sur une
chaise de bureau qui voyez la caméra
n'est vraiment en face de lui il est en
train de il est sur un bureau quoi un
peu comme moi comme voilà par contre
vous voyez que ce la caméra elle est en
dessous de sa tête
et donc en fait moi je ne sais pas ce
que j'ai la caméra de devant et derrière
mais si je vous mets juste pour rire si
je vous mets la caméra que j'ai derrière
lui parce que j'ai une caméra regardez
vous êtes vous la trouver la caméra
vous allez comprendre est-ce que vous
voyez comment il joue
il a une chaise d'ordi comme moi mais
sur la génération au lieu de s'asseoir
il baisse son ordi et il a pris une
chaise de bureau sur laquelle il est
assis et comme ça il fait tout le temps
comme ça et je ne sais pas pourquoi il
fait ça c'est incroyable et comme si je
t'ai vu il avait pas assez d'argent pour
s'acheter un une table quoi et en fait
il est
il est il est accroupi
accroupi sur son ordinateur et la souris
il a un espace il fait comme ça que ta
souris il a pas il a pas de d'espace
pour jouer quoi c'est assez incroyable
et bon c'est c'est saut ça il le fait à
chaque événement tout le temps pareil et
le pire c'est même amulette il reste
comme ça et il est rapide il est quand
il y a plus de temps il veut faire vite
et il arrive à jouer comme ça et ce qui
est assez incroyable c'est que même là
franchement au bout de trois heures de
jeu c'est quand même mal tu vois déjà
même moi rester ici en face de mon
ordinateur j'ai mal au dos j'ai mal au
dos quand je finis l'événement mais
alors lui il a accroupi c'est c'est
vraiment assez atypique et assez
impressionnant à la fois donc donc voilà
la première fois j'avais complètement
halluciné
comme j'avais enfin quand j'avais quand
j'avais vu je pensais que il était pas
chez lui que c'était vraiment
exceptionnel etc en fait non tout le
temps comme ça
c'est incroyable alors j'ai quatre
étages par Wesley c'est hyper chaud il
donne le la qualité donc là il faut
calculer qu'est-ce qui se passe si je
peux manger ou pas
parce que tu reprends c'est sûrement ce
qui va vouloir faire
mater mais c'est chaud est-ce que je te
mate est-ce que j'ai rangé 7 38 où
est-ce que j'arrive à atmater est-ce que
j'ai du je sais pas des trucs quoi
qu'elle va les prendre F7 avec un projet
6 ça a pas l'air trop marcher je crois
que par Majorie je crois que le roi
s'échappe mais c'est c'est chaud en tout
cas j'ai 4 ou un peu l'ambition de cette
partie il veut mater le roi de
Levana qui prend son fou et ceux qui
fait tout reprend G4 il avait il avait
PRIMOVE ton projet 4
oui tu peux néo vas-y
ouais tu peux la poster alors j'ai enfin
publié sur YouTube la vidéo dans
laquelle je passe mettre international
donc dans ce qui sont dans le chat qui
voudraient plus tard après le stream
bien évidemment jeter un œil et ben vous
avez le lien posté gentiment par néo
merci à toi
donc j'ai trois
avec tes jouets
tourage
toujours envie de jouer je pense que je
suis pas sûr que ça marche et ça ça la
chose elle n'aime pas mais en pratique
c'est chaud le roi qui se balade
des deux
mystérieux 30 secondes pour les blancs
contre une minute 16
ca va les prendre je vais fous prends
échec et d'apprendre
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on fait cavaler prend
intermédiaire mais le tour prend ici je
vais me tendre bien
ça marche pas
comment est-ce qu'on joue c'est hyper
compliqué de tout reprendre
j'ai deux probablement mais à quoi F7
que se passe-t-il ici
parce que sur roi prend un chèque avec
Dame prend et à plus madame en prise
c'est le problème
salut Olympe
voilà c'est quoi la suite
du mal à trouver la suite
parce qu'à tout emprise en fait
maintenant je suis cloué
si je prends là
voilà c'est très compliqué la gars tout
en prise c'est ce cavalet est en prison
tu reprends un F4
le roi qui est complètement à poil
comment est-ce que je punissais à votre
cavalier prend faut prendre
il faut prendre avec les jouets
tactiques sur ces deux
tours donc même pas la tour nous on veut
essayer de ramener la tour ici faire un
masque par là-haut cavalier
5 est-ce qu'il va manger ici peut-être
même pas il prend la nul
ici peut-être c'est quand même c'est
quand même tendu je crois qu'il va
prendre la nul
pour cette première game et 5 qui avait
l'air très tendu il y a plus de chèques
que je défends tout
mais j'ai une tour d'avance avec les
blancs mais j'ai un roi je sens que
c'est extrêmement dur dame G7 ordinateur
et seul coup c'est roi H4 je me lasse
maintenant
sur mon ordinateur mais les coûts sont
forcés quoi quelle horreur pour les deux
joueurs c'est une torture
ok donc la partie ça fait nul deuxième
partie
hop je tourne
l'échiquier je mets le score un jour
les points c'est
alors si vous le voulez je peux aussi
vous mettre des titres des petites
prédiction sur le sur le chat ainsi si
vous voulez récupérer vos points et
l'eau et vous
récupérez vos points de chaîne les
points perdus durement ou gagner
d'ailleurs à cause de cette prédiction
je peux aussi vous en faire si vous êtes
intéressé par tout ça ça fait un petit
peu de
l'événement un peu plus vers l'intérieur
donc
ici pour l'instant hop je vais fermer ça
un demi un demi pour nos joueurs là on a
encore une Sicilienne
Caval 5 on va jouer F4 c'est l'idée de
d'aronium avec les Blancs ici donc c'est
un joueur qui est vraiment très créatif
qui essaye tout le temps de jeu pour le
gain et c'est aussi un truc qui est très
apprécié
pour nous un spectateur on aime bien
avoir des spectacles on a bien voir voir
des parties enfin de belles parties sauf
aussi il est comme ça merceau il aime
beaucoup plus solide alors qu'on connaît
plus solide plutôt que harmonial c'est
un genre un peu plus fantasme donc on
préfère un petit peu les joueurs qui
font un peu le spectacle et on espère
voir aronia dans cette partie nous faire
un petit peu le chaud
même c'est vrai qu'on a vu la partie
d'avant on a vu aussi
on a vu ça fait toutes ces pièces pour
mater le roi de leven en Onion et au
final ça m'a fait nul après une belle
bataille
salut à toi
toujours présent
c'est un peu ma der de la semaine
normalement après vous me voyez plus la
semaine
en tout cas pas sur cette chaîne là
par contre je serai de retour le 11 le
lundi 11
pour un seul match et après vous je re
disparaître pendant très longtemps
là vous avez mon planning
alors dessin qui a été joué l'idée c'est
d'essayer d'ouvrir un peu la position
des fous vous voyez j'ai deux fous
magnifique braquée sur le roi noir ce
qui veut c'est ouvrir la position pour
essayer de mater le roi de Wesley donc
ça donne un pion mais pas vraiment parce
que vous emprise pour cavaler prend qui
défend le fou et ben je sais 4
et ça par exemple
donc il y a eu prise
tout rembours
C4 pour défendre le pont
le fou qui va venir en B2 et là vraiment
j'aime énormément la position d'aroniame
avec les Blancs on peut imaginer
quelque chose comme dame Detroit
une batterie sur la diagonale blanche
et ça a l'air pas mal du tout ces
petites choses
rien qui existe pas un relevé élégant
alors ça qui permet pas ah oui non mais
c'est clair
il est vraiment c'est vraiment un joueur
très créatif qui
qui
est toujours là toujours présent
non je pars pas mais en fait juste j'ai
eu un petit un petit rush on va dire de
commentaires sur twitch dernièrement je
commande chez tour et juste après je
suis je commande le speechestre mais je
vais pas faire tout de suite et
tata style non plus c'est Laurent qui
fait ta style
et là je commente je grandis hier et
aujourd'hui mais après dans la semaine
je crois que en tout cas il y a rien de
prévu pour moi
donc normalement je ne coûterai plus sur
tes sommet à faire de la semaine mais
lundi je reviens pour un autre
commentaire
mais après je ne m'aurai plus de la
semaine donc encore une fois là ça va
être ponctuel alors que là ça fait ça
fait plus d'une semaine que fait tous
les jours sur sur twitch avec vous sur
tout ce qu'on va faire
donc voilà ce que là
et non je ne compte pas t'express
je suis passé sur son stream il avait
l'air de bien s'en sortir
c'est que souvent ça a été ton problème
il avait peur un peu de la
technique
mais ça a l'air de bien se passer
donc cool
dame C1
probablement à vouloir ici taper sur la
belle diagonale et sur le four le fou G7
et ouais Damas c'est joli hein manœuvre
dame
assez joli
de le virer un peu H4 sur de très très
très moche avec un jour des idées comme
cavailler 4 pour venir ici ce serait
moche en tout cas mais ici vu qu'il y a
un clouage peut-être que c'est possible
mais c'est moi j'aime pas
j'aime pas c'est cavale le 4 c'est
cavaliers
de gagner le CASE noir c'est un beau
coup qui force cavalier 8 h 7
tours
alors là il y a peut-être un moyen de
gagner du matériel ou pas
une petite caballer prend chaque
cavalier prend pour prendre
même pas non plus vous voyez à chaque
fois j'ai mal du couloir
pour ce problème final
H3 de jouer
comment est-ce qu'on continue les Noirs
ont un problème d'espace vous voyez que
j'ai du mal à bouger mes pièces je suis
cloué de partout c'est pas parce qu'il
est cloué ce fou bouge pas parce qu'il a
pas de case défend le cavalier
et là il fait ça je pense son lieu de
cavaliers 8 pour échanger les fous que
moyen de pièces
plus j'ai de chance
de Me ressortir de me sortir de là quoi
et puis on pas grand chose mais on
superposition quoi c'est à dire que j'ai
trouvé bien sur la meilleure casse
possible
et malgré tout et ben ça a pas l'air de
suffire
c'est dur de
c'est dur hein
quand vous comparez les pièces blanches
et noir on a l'impression que c'est
vraiment un fiasco point noir ici mais
au final
faut prendre à me prendre et cavalier 6
le retour probablement
ok
il a bien raison
il a bien raison il faut changer les
pièces donc vous avez moins d'espace que
l'adversaire et bien à cause de l'espace
donc échanger toutes les pièces que vous
pouvez
à 3 à 5
et aussi apprendre les trois qui est qui
peut être une idée pour attaquer sur le
plan B3 prise ca va les prendre
dans ma tête alors la prise ici va
sûrement avoir lieu ce fou c'est eux qui
est une mauvaise pièce
toutes les changer sauf le fou c'est
deux mauvaises pièces derrière c'est
pion je prends moi je prends et je fais
ça
mais qu'est-ce qu'ils vont revivre alors
que ce fou est mauvais donc
c'est vrai que mon cavalu aussi en G7
c'est pas une très bonne pièce non plus
il va en D7 en fuite pardon Jean
[Musique]
5 c'est vraiment une partie de manœuvre
qu'on va avoir donc attaque un peu tout
le monde donc ça a forcé l'échange de
dames
et maintenant comment est-ce qu'on
continue j'aime bien les Noirs quand
même malgré la position qui est
difficile ce fou il est tellement
mauvais que j'aime bien les Noirs je me
dis que si on arrive à changer les
pièces
pour avoir quelques options même si ça a
l'air quand même assez
nul comme position mais
je pense que si il y a plus de cavaliers
c'est les noirs qui pourraient essayer
de pousser
il y a pas grand chose mais
c'est fou est tellement mauvais que
c'est une possibilité mais je pense pas
qu'il va le faire
parce qu'il sait avoir que s'il bouge le
cavalier ok ça fait nul
deux parties d'affilée
deux nuls
on est toujours à un partout
dans ce match
allez c'est un système de Londres il
faut que j'ai quatre images
arrivé
3 OK
Wesley
[Musique]
ouvrir son roi
C4 coûte très logique de la part de
Wesley le foot 15 blanche des noirs est
parti du coup lui de ce côté il va
ouvrir les caches blanches de ce côté là
c'est comme ça même fou il y a trois pas
de possible aussi
moi je m'en fous tu manges quand tu veux
je mange du purger de toute façon
après je pourrais même roquer c'est pas
grave d'avoir de faire je prends sa
position beaucoup de gens pensent que
bah moi il est ouvert du coup je
pourrais plus ok etc mais en fait c'est
pas si grave parce que si vous regardez
les pièces noires c'est pas si facile
H3 bien joué
car elle prend ici on prend le fou et
maintenant
le cavalier noir qui est un petit peu
mal placé
en G6
j'aime bien la position de Wesley ici
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup ce qui fait en
cette partie il faut des trois dame
c'est de
la F4 peut-être une possibilité
j'aime beaucoup la position
G3 est un coup pour empêcher les chèques
je sais pas si c'est grave de bouger le
roi peut-être sur fouiller chaque
maintenant je ferai un roi ou deux je
pense que c'est pas grave du tout au
contraire on est content parce qu'on
gagnerait un temps en plus après ça ça
je pourrais même menacer gs5 et le faux
sera enfermé qui avait l'air froid pour
aller manger donc faut H4 c'est vraiment
pas le goût du siècle
donc des retours d'échecs après j'ai pas
les pièces qui suivent derrière ça sert
à rien
retenez-le bien ça donc tous les trois
on sent les pièces d'ailleurs je pense
peut-être même que vous êtes parti il
est possible que ce garde le roi au
centre
donc il est possible qu'il fasse un
grand rock on a entendu mais aussi
possible que le roi reste en 2
[Musique]
de
à moins qu'il ait envie de ramener la
dame en H3 ça serait bien mais bon c'est
dur de ramener la dame là bas c'est un
long voyage ça fait trois petits coups
je suis pas sûr qu'il ait le temps et
qu'il a envie de faire tout ça
le pion H7
en cible cavalier qui va venir F3
la question on peut manger en bêtises
donc si je B4 et le problème de P4
maintenant et bien ce qu'il y a à 5
et sur A3 tout va se changer mais vous
voyez maintenant à toi on n'a pas
défendu contrairement à tout à l'heure
quand la dame était en C1 et ben la même
idée j'aurais pu à chaque fois faire ça
parce que du coup la dame défendait la
tour et garder une belle structure avec
les Blancs
donc là il y a eu beaucoup de 6 je veux
par show
qui est logique
comme maintenant après une prise donc on
peut imaginer quand même
apprendre qu'elle a quand même assez
logique la colonne ah je savais ouverte
on a pas trop envie d'ouvrir afin de
recul de ce côté là c'est ça qui a été
joué encore mieux donc
pour l'activité et c'est plutôt bien
joué j'ai l'impression
un regard qui est qui a une position
difficile avec l'attaque quand même sur
le roi blanc tu vois ici je veux
dynamique et essayer de poser des
problèmes à l'adversaire donc F5 a été
joué
sur F5 c'est assez compliqué parce que
le cadre est noir c'est pas trop il va
aller s'il va en h6 il peut y avoir un
motif assez sympa je vous le montre
attendez un roulement ce que je pensais
un truc comme F6 pouvait être sympa
menace vous prend un J7 matte mignon
très mignon
et donc il faut à chaque échec
croiser un
et C4 si je mange là tu manges là pour
manger chaque roi bouge
compliqué
ici mais j'aurais tout reprend
et si maintenant tu fais fou de là
c'est un peu la partie pour l'instant
j'ai plus ce petit coef6
et sur F6 du coup que je commence
évidemment
mais j'ai l'impression que saut est
complètement gagnant
complètement gagnant il y a probablement
sur le pont H7 vous voyez
sur le fou ici sur le cavalier H8 il y a
plein de problèmes dans la position
noire
fou j'ai 5 on va manger ici alors
attention le roi par OK je chante bien
je serais plus Rocket
le 4 alors pas mal pour chasser un peu
le cavalier
salut à toi Cécile et merci beaucoup
sous le royaume pour le pour le raid
merci à toi
désolé et allez voir un petit peu ce que
fait notre ami supplément maillot sur
twitch je fais des échecs donc merci
encore pour le raid
et n'hésitez pas à aller visiter son son
stream donc ta recette a été joué
et ici qu'est-ce qu'on fait
c'est l'impression qu'il y a des maths
de partout ça va commencer par F6
non la chose qui est même pas bougé
quand j'ai dit ça incroyable d'un proche
prenais là haut
il a pas joué mon cou il a joué un autre
coup là je crois c'est deux qui permet
aussi avec les Dramé la tour
[Musique]
par là un jour pareil
B3 pour défendre et ramener la tour par
ici mais F6 tout à l'heure gagné direct
gros blender de la part de saut qui a
raté un gain que même je touche
donc c'est dire vraiment
c'était pas si compliqué c'est tout la
vue
j'ai 4 a été joué
ce petit pion en prise
maintenant probablement tout rachat va
être joué et tout rachat 4 en l'air il y
a deux en l'air il y a pas mal de trucs
en l'air
mais la position blanche hein quand même
assez solide
c'est solide
enlève le contre-jeu ici là
pour les banques
il y a un peu tout en l'air attention
pas de cavaluation qui va te reprendre
ici
salut je t'attends je t'attends avant de
faire des prédits je t'attends je savais
que tu que tu en voulais je me suis dit
je me suis dit si je balance la prédit
alors qu'il est pas encore arrivé il va
m'en vouloir et du coup je t'attendais
par contre ça je l'avais pas 19 secondes
pour pour qui est très très mal au temps
mais qui a une position qui est
complètement gagnante donc c'est la rive
c'est une panique pas et qu'il arrive
à terminer
et ben ça va le faire ta me F5 pour
jouer fou ces deux peut-être une bonne
solution même tout RAV4 pas mal aussi
avec Dame C7 les problèmes sur GSM aussi
sur la tour
et la dame qui a été sacrifiée par saut
pour faire un joli petit mètre regardez
tous ces deux et chaque IMAX c'est pas
magnifique
franchement soit il fait un très très
bon début de match
ce qui fait un très très bon début de
match
[Musique]
italienne avec
avec que prend des cinq kg
3 le fou qui peut toujours venir manger
ce cavalier en H3
food 2 il y a plein de cookies qui
existent néo mais en tout cas en tout
cas
ça existe le fou 2 aussi qui avait l'âge
3 tout ça c'est cette théorique c'est
des coups qui qui existent
merci à toi God and RAF merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup pour ton petit message
c'était effectivement très difficile
pour moi après cette partie perdue
contre le joueur à 16
et c'était un petit peu je pense ma pire
expérience je sais qu'il aime que j'ai
pu vivre et je suis content de la
réaction que j'ai que j'ai su avoir
après cette défaite parce que j'ai
enchaîné deux gros tournoi de très bons
résultats
alors que généralement à l'époque quand
je faisais des motards comme ça ou des
mauvais résultats j'étais capable de me
saccager et de tout perdre en arrière
parce que je vais trouver et que je
voulais plus
[Musique]
et un peu parti de tout tomber et de
tout bâcler et notamment donné mon
objectif etc
et là j'ai vraiment changé à ce niveau
là et j'ai réussi à vraiment mobiliser
il y a c'est de bien jouer
et ça s'est bien passé comme ça content
de ce que j'ai réussi à faire derrière
mais donc voilà merci beaucoup en tout
cas ça me fait plaisir
vous deux a été joué
tournoi comme c'est flou chez moi je
sais pas lire
alors c'est le speech Championship donc
c'est un tournoi pour vous montrer tout
à l'heure si vous voulez éventuellement
d'ici environ 10 minutes il y aura une
pause pour les joueurs et je voudrais un
petit peu le bracket vous savez c'est un
système coupe par élimination cette
fois-ci c'est une version directe quand
tu perds le mal tu es éliminé c'est ciao
c'est pas il y a pas poule de gagnant
pour les parents là c'est vraiment les
minettes tu perds tu t'en vas
et il y a encore un beau plateau on a
carcène on a encore Nakamura on a encore
des joueurs extrêmement fort on a vu
hier on a vu hier Nakamura qui jouait
contre Lyon
19 en juin que du Arthur complètement
débile donc il a voulu il est alors mode
troll complet contre you
et donc là c'est un autre événement il y
a sa marque top 3 heures il y a une
heure et demie de partie en 5 plus une
heure de trois plus une et ensuite une
demi-heure de Bullet une puce voilà donc
c'est c'est chaud
c'est chaud
tu as le format qui est aussi affiché en
dessous de moi là ici pas vous montrer
mais pas loin qui est affiché ici
qui te explique le match de Max
ime sans dire de bêtises c'est le 8
septembre
vendredi
je crois bien que ça vendredi et ceux
qui qui pousse vraiment à rognanes cette
partie là vous voyez les pièces blanches
qui n'arrivent pas à s'exprimer
et ça m'a l'air très très grave pour
pour
Harmonia dans cette partie
à Royan qui est mené déjà à deux mains
dans ce match perd une deuxième partie
d'affilée ce serait pas la bonne
nouvelle en tout cas pour lui
il est très très mal dans cette partie
Endel il va je contre goût Kesh si
j'étais pas de bêtises on pourra
vérifier si vous voulez environ 10
minutes il y aura une il y aura une
pause donc à la pause on regardera un
petit peu le bracket si vous voulez
ensemble je crois que c'est mvl bocage
et mvl pour moi il va être gros
favori dans ce match même si
même si Google je ta maman bah c'est un
peu l'homme à battre c'est le jeune
talent indien qui gagne tout ce qui vous
avec Prague c'est vraiment les les deux
qui sont les plus impressionnants dans
les combats mais je pense que Maxime
reste quand même un gros favori dans ce
format là je crois que Google c'est pas
trop son truc
les petites sur Internet et Maxime on
sait on sait déjà que c'est un des
meilleurs joueurs online un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde donc là dans
ce format là
donc je pense que Maxime gros favori
en tout cas il part big favoris
é
ment j'ai rien dit je suis fatigué
aujourd'hui je suis fatigué
c'est fou c'est fou j'ai fait avant de
venir ici j'ai fait la Tuesday et j'ai
fait un tournoi catastrophique donc je
pense que bon voilà mon commentaire sur
la tour en prise et ben reflète un peu
le résultat que j'ai fait dans tout mon
tournoi j'ai fait une très mauvaise fin
F3 là pas mal là
on a envie de venir taquiner ce fou ce
cavalier tout son casse blanche c'est
extrêmement dur ici pour les blancs
donc c'est mat quasiment de partout
il y a plein plein de possibilités il y
a pas de maths direct je crois mais en
tout cas ça a l'air très prometteur pour
les pour les Noirs les Blancs
pas de coup les pièces sont mal placées
ultra faible ramener une dame ici ce
serait bien dame Décathlon ça c'est une
menace
plus tard 500 sera une autre le Caval
qui a pas de casse de repli par achat et
venir en H1 c'est quand même la loose et
cavaliers
dehors donc c'est ça va pas du tout la
main a été joué d'apprendre H5 c'est
quoi les bailles
non il y a pas d'emprise
pas du tout
il y a pas d'échec là il y a pas d'échec
là
[Musique]
il y a ça en prise de fois indéfendable
on a vu la tête qu'il a fait il l'a raté
mais de toute façon la position était
cuite donc
c'est pas vrai
et comme tu es moins bien
pour
Wesley il faut abandonner et passer à la
suivante allez abandon
on passe à la suivante
hop là
pour mettre les points à jour
ça fait trois ans pour ça pour ce match
salut les copains
en fait c'est un joueur qui est
normalement qui est extrêmement solide
et
qui sait quand même dire sa chance quand
on lui donne c'est pas le joueur
normalement qui va partir à la date qui
va mater c'est pas un furros déjà c'est
pas un joueur comme Maxime c'est pas un
genre comme ça c'est un joueur qui est
très solide et il comprend bien les
échecs et pour moi c'est un des
candidats
pour vraiment un jour d'être né Magnus
il a une période
sur quelques années où tout ce qu'il
faisait île de gagner c'était assez
monstrueux et du coup moi j'ai toujours
pensé qu'il avait un potentiel
intéressant mais soit il a je trouve
qu'il a un problème un peu
psychologique plein de fois il sent
qu'il a inférieur à son adversaire ou
plein de choses comme ça et donc du coup
des fois on dirait il n'ose pas faire
certaines choses alors que je trouve
vraiment c'est un super Viber genre
je pense qu'il pourrait être en mille
fois meilleur que ce qu'il est
actuellement
mais
il a un style plus solide généralement
alors car rognan c'est plus la
créativité c'est plus le joueur qui va
attaquer et qui fera des calculs
j'avais vu un superbe beau match
on l'avait vu bon c'était la Coupe du
monde alors je sais plus en quelle année
je dirais 2020 2021
c'était la demi-finale du match entre
Maxime bah c'est la Grave mvl et Aronian
ils avaient fait un match mais de folie
et si tu arrives à magédon et c'était
Maxime qui avait perdu alors qu'il était
complètement gagnant
c'était la folie
mais un match un match de malade mental
et dans chaque partie il prenait des
coups il se rendait des coups c'était
vraiment le le gros combat de boxe quoi
et hyper impressionnant et
donc elle revient c'est vraiment un
joueur qui
[Musique]
qui cherche des choses qui créent des
choses
c'est un peu même style que Maxime en
fait en plus solide peut-être un peu
plus
Maxime il est plus envoyer encore je
pense que
que les vannes
et pourtant les von armagnan c'est un
joueur qui adore sont compliquées il
adore tout ça
normalement il refuse pas trop les
challenges de ce type là que vous voyez
ici là il y a tout en prise il y a ça en
prises il y a un clouage qui refuse pas
généralement tu vois que ça c'est
intéressant vous allez voir à ronium qui
va toujours aller
dans le sens des complications
aussi plus fort que d'autres malgré tout
la génération ah oui la nouvelle
génération
[Musique]
au moins 5 que les cités qui ont plus de
2007 et qui vont être extrêmement
dangereux pour les anciens
quand je parle d'anciens c'est
mvl c'est c'est à rognan c'est
ma tenue car voilà
tous ces jours là
il est
encore là il est quand même pas loin de
2700 hello farine et ça fait au moins un
an ou deux que farine il a le même hello
et qui il arrive plus à
monter on va voir un peu chez la percer
aussi mais on a l'impression qu'il a un
petit problème qui il est un peu bloqué
là selon
le petit le petit Sarine j'aime bien ce
petit coup faut prendre assise j'aime
beaucoup ce coup de saut alors pourquoi
j'aime bien ce coup va regarder bien ce
fou sur un champ gâteau il est très
mauvais et quand je mange ici et bah du
coup comme ça une mauvaise pièce je
l'échange et après faut prendre le C4 et
là vous allez voir à quel point ce fou
en A6 va devenir mauvais il a plus qu'il
porte de sortie
ce fou est complètement enfermé donc
c'est vraiment très très bien joué de la
part de
[Musique]
la part de saut et maintenant je vais
garder cette structure à vie pour que le
fou assise ne puisse jamais rejouer de
sa vie
à la pollution
stratégiquement elle est perdure
stratégiquement elle est perdue pour les
Noirs parce que je joue une pièce de moi
on va partir on va faire un truc j'ai
une pièce de moins sur le chéquier si
jamais j'arrive à garder ma structure
oui je suis d'accord que ça rime je
pense qu'il a fait trop de Bullet il
était un petit peu moins
un petit peu moins bosseur peut-être que
les autres mais en plus ça rien
que les Pragues que les je crois que ça
rime un an plus que Prague qui a un en
plus que vous cache
il a pas vu non plus hein
mais bon
ça va
ok comment on continue maintenant est-ce
que
peut un jour être une idée
est-ce qu'il veut pas faire tout à 8 et
manger le four
de H4 tranquillement améliorer la
position au fur et à mesure et se dire
que bah écoute moi je joue avec plein de
pièces
il a fait mon cou et là le pion de B3 il
est quand même bien bétonné voyage je
vais mettre plein de pièces dessus allez
roi G2
voilà H4
[Musique]
d'ici pour mettre la dame ici pour une
bonne idée
je pense en tout cas je pense que c'est
une
grosse possibilité
pour l'instant car c'est encore devant
mais les jeunes gars je suis à quel âge
il est même pas encore majeur
il est encore jeune
Marius tu as 33
il est vieux maintenant
vous imaginez la double de l'âge de
Google
donc oui 45 milliard jouable on est
d'accord actuellement
tu peux rien faire mais bon ils sont
encore hyper jeunes Magnus à l'âge de à
l'âge de Google
enfin ils étaient en train de bousculer
vraiment l'élite donc on va voir en tout
cas il y a encore du boulot pour Google
ils sont extrêmement forts
mais bon
94 ça fait très très mal les Cavaillac
qui arrive aussi ça a l'air ou abandon
direct avant on dirait que tu as un
homme qui qui c'est la pause c'est la
pause on va voir cette partie juste
après pour que ça fait quand même un
petit 4 1%
difficile pour pouvoir rognan ce start
il y a eu deux nuls et trois défaites
d'affilée pour Aronian harmonial qui qui
a besoin d'aller prendre un petit peu
l'air et boire un truc manger un truc on
va faire un truc pour changer un petit
peu
j'ai changé un petit peu
tout ça alors regardez rapidement le
bracket tout à l'heure me l'a demandé
alors vous avez ici c'est donc c'est
élimination directe donc il y a pas du
tout de comment dire
de double bracket double perdant tu
perds une fois le match tu es éliminé là
on a vu le match hier Nakamura contre
éliminé il est plus là donc à moi est
encore de finale en dessous on a saut
contre aronial donc le match joué à voir
que le gagnant de ce match là je rentre
le gagnant de firu contre andrikim donc
intéressant
on a aussi Carolin contre Abdou pour
avoir aussi Sarine contre sarrana et
Maxime contre bouquet gros gros match
que vous verrez le
8 donc le vendredi 8 septembre vous
verrez
et
ensuite vous aurez aussi à 45 minutes 45
qui est pour qui est le joueur qui gagne
absolument tous les tournois auxquels
ils participent à gagner la Coupe du
Monde récemment il a gagné aussi le
champions 3 semaines dernière et il a
encore dans le speechester cette semaine
donc car scène il s'est rend bien
plaisir en mettant tous ces petits
événements et et très content de jouer
contre la jeune génération là il y a
encore j'avais dit en gagnant il pourra
jouer Ding ou irrigazi puis après
éventuellement furosa bref c'est encore
un super événement et salut à toi Lotus
j'espère que tu vas bien Lotus
si gros contre mvl oui il peut y avoir
des très bon match mais fearu mvl il se
joueront
en 2001 si il se joue
non pardon ils auront en finale parce
que je raconte qu'est-ce que je raconte
mais il faudra que mvl passe Naka et kif
pascalsen
[Musique]
de gros gros gros match en tout cas
c'est un bel événement donc 4 1 pour
l'instant pour ceux qui est qui est
assez en forme dans ce dans ce match et
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils vont enlever les
parties de
je vais vous remettre un petit peu je
vais revenir sur ça
[Musique]
écoute Lotus ça va plutôt bien
ça a plutôt bien André kine c'est un peu
de la Russie mais tu sais qu'en ce
moment avec ce qui se passe
c'est ça le drapeau de la fille mais
avec ce qui se passe entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine et ben la Russie a été dan de
la feed donc les joueurs jouent sous un
drapeau qui n'est pas un polar aussi bon
c'est une longue histoire
et voilà
bientôt GM non non pas moi
pas moi un autre peut-être mais Lotus
peut-être mais moi non non c'est pas
demain que je serai grand maître grand
maître c'est un autre niveau je n'ai pas
du tout le niveau ni les compétences ni
le temps de travailler pour tout ça
duel de foie américain alors je suis à
moitié d'accord avec toi quand même
Emmanuel Guignard je suis obligé
d'accord avec toi
on va on va en parler
on va en parler
je connais très très bien l'histoire de
sauge c'est très bien l'histoire
d'ammoniaque je peux très bien toute
leur histoire
je connais la histoire la raison pour
laquelle et ben ils ont changé de
pays mais bon c'est
sorti ouais lotus est sorti toi tu l'as
vu en direct à avoine
voilà en fait so Wesley il est quand
même issu alors je sais plus si c'est le
père ou la mère qui est qui finit pas et
l'autre qui est américain et toute sa
vie il a vécu comme aux États-Unis c'est
un peu comme comme Cavana qui est
italien
il a un parent italien un parent
américain et en fait ben tu es toute ta
vie aux États-Unis et
et tu as le drapeau qui est peut-être ta
maman ou ton papa mais tu es toute ta
vie dans ce pays là bah en finale tu
sais même pas commencer la Filippine à
un moment donné je suis d'accord que tu
as plus envie de te présenter les
États-Unis c'est toute ta vie tu habites
quoi donc pour ça c'est un peu un cas
différent par contre aronia nous il y a
eu un problème de de
la fédération de son pays un problème de
soutien il disait que la fête des ne se
tient jamais et que il y a bref donc
moi je pars là je suis un peu moins
d'accord parce que malgré tout tu restes
quand même enfin tu as aucune racine des
États-Unis mais après voilà c'est un
choix c'est autorisé pas de souci de
débat mais par contre pour ça je trouve
que c'est différent c'est comme Nakamura
les Japonais hein
mais bon toute sa vie il est né aux
États-Unis enfin il est pour lui 100%
américain en fait donc en fait Nakamura
ben oui c'est pas un nom américain
solo non plus Dominguez c'est pareil de
Wings il est il est cubain
et sauf que là-bas à Cuba donc vous
savez qu'il y a des problèmes avec Cuba
Etats-Unis ça encore une fois Cuba
Etats-Unis bon c'est encore notre
histoire mais il y a eu énormément de
problèmes etc avec aussi de soutien de
plein de choses et bon bref nous on a
Fiero oui mais encore une fois cette
fois c'est la fille
Dominguez c'est plus des raisons
politiques
que des raisons personnelles
alors que par exemple Saône à kamura
Kawana les mecs ils habitent leur vie
quoi enfin c'est comme toi tu t'es je
sais pas
tu es n'importe quel pays donc tu es
Arméniens et en fait tu es né en France
tu es toute ta vie en France ton père
est français ta mère est l'Arménienne
mais sont un peu parmi depuis toujours
mais tu connais pas l'arménité
si jamais allé en fait je peux
comprendre que tu as envie de tel pays
qui correspond le mieux
et qui habite depuis 30 ans bah écoute
tu veux être enfin je veux mon drapeau
comme ça quoi enfin moi je le vois comme
ça après je trouve pas mais
quand on a vraiment tu viens de ce pays
je vois pas pourquoi il y aurait il y
aurait en fait
débat quoi après oui quand tu quand tu
n'y es pas et tu y vas pour l'argent ça
c'est autre chose après si c'est
autorisé par la par la fille mais il y a
pas de débat en fait tu as le droit de
faire même si bon
oui voilà mais après quand tu es sur les
deux à la limite tu peux toujours tu
vois il y a un débat tu peux te sentir
plus appartenir
à un pays que d'autres alors que
alors que là saut toute sa vie tu as
vécu aux États-Unis quoi donc
garder le drapeau de Philippines
franchement
je comprends après pourquoi pas si tu
veux comme Cabana il a juste il a
l'hospitalie jusqu'à très tard alors
qu'il habitait toute sa vie
aux États-Unis à Saint-Louis je crois
qu'il habite là-bas et toute sa vie il
avait le drapeau italien pendant très
longtemps et après bon finalement je
vais changer ok peut-être aussi les
grands financières aussi à ça mais bon
toute sa vie il a vécu aux États-Unis
c'est normal qu'ils sont plus américain
italien peut comprendre bref passons
mais je vais à peu près les grandes
lignes mais bon c'est plus politique
encore une fois que que il est pas une
racine de la balle un magasin c'est une
partie échec ou le joueur qui joue avec
les Noirs gagne si la match nul c'est ça
est à Noël et encore une fois si jamais
si jamais on fait comment dire s'il y a
un magreton ce sera joué sur avec
enchères encore une fois ils aiment bien
les enchères je crois maintenant
alors on est reparti sur la même
ouverture que tout à l'heure avec
aronial qui joue
son petit système
car je crois
ok finalement c'est H3 d'abord ici pour
empêcher un truc en G4 et après on joue
des cartes
les enchères alors oui bonne question
alors pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi le
champion de chaise tour ça se passe
comme ça en gros chaque il y a deux
joueurs qui vont proposer un temps alors
je sais pas combien de temps ça va être
par contre je sais qu'il y a des
enchères mais je sais pas quel cadence
c'est de base imaginons pour le chemin
en 15 minutes + 3 secondes et donc pour
le l'Armageddon et genre avec 15 minutes
chacun mais en fait les joueurs
proposent
une cadence avec laquelle ils sont
d'accord d'avoir les Noirs par exemple
moi je prends les Noirs mais si j'ai par
exemple 9 minutes
et moi je dis ok mais 9-32 en fait le
joueur qui aura donné le temps le plus
bas des deux va obtenir les noirs
et du coup en cas de nul et ben il se
qualifie voilà donc tu as les Noirs tu
as 9 minutes contre 15 minutes mais ça
fait nul tu te qualifier il y a blanc
ont beaucoup plus de temps que toi mais
doivent gagner absolument donc les deux
joueurs sont un peu handicapés et c'est
censé être à peu près juste comme
système
donc en tout cas on verra ça c'est les
enchères
un magreton
on le fera nous ensemble c'est dans les
tournois comme ça système coupe les
tournois qui sont par l'émulation
directe où tu iras des armagidants en
cas d'égalité
voilà
alors
il y a un problème sur le petit pion des
pour débuter
est-ce qu'on peut voir ici un coup du
type je sais pas si ça va être bon mais
du type cavalier 3 pour venir en dessin
que ça est-ce que c'est débile ou est-ce
que c'est intéressant
IRL tu l'as aussi on a vu déjà je plat
de France cette année je peux la France
maintenant qui se déroule en système
direct et on a eu des matchs dans la
maison
on a vu la Girel qui a un contre
les
je crois que c'était Maxime Lagarde
contre
romain noir
en magasin
comme ça
donc bon
j'aime beaucoup ce coup
parce que fougères ici il est fou prend
F3 pour mettre un joli cavalier en de 4
qui sera pas contesté par le cavalier F3
voyez les classes si jamais fait à la
place qu'avec les quatre car elle prend
puis on prend ou tu reprends peau c'est
une partie c'est bien pour les pour les
Noirs mais fougères pour manger le
cavalier et ensuite mettre le cavalor
des quatre c'est super pour les noirs et
aussi à noter que le fou en G3 il me
fait beaucoup penser à une partie qui
est très connue je pense que la voisine
dans le chat la partie
partie extrêmement connue où le fou
reste en 23 qui peut me la donner dans
le chat
est-ce que vous connaissez cette partie
une partie commence dans toutes les
écoles
contre qui la joué
partie qui est très connue voir si vous
avez appris votre leçon et salut
merci à toi merci à toi pour ton petit
message très cool oui merci
Magnus touffe
non non
c'était incapable en cas contre winter
parti très connue ou en fait il y avait
un fou enfermé en G3 mais c'est pas
quand même la même position parce qu'ici
je peux toujours bouger mon fou ça F3
farfouille F2 et m'en fous qui peut qui
peut regarder winter seul sur le chat
incroyable winter qui est encore vivant
une partie qui s'est joué dans les
années 1900
regardez dans l'autre partie il y avait
des pions doublés F3 et F2 comme ça et
en fait le fou était condamné et vous
pouvez jamais sortir de son trou il y
avait des pions en G5 avec les Noirs je
pouvais jamais faire F4 vous pouvez
jamais sortir de mon fou là je peux
encore sortir mon fou mon faux F2 donc
c'est quand même pas pareil que la
partie 2 winter cette fameuse partie
mais ça lui ressemble un petit peu au
niveau de la de la position on s'en fout
qui est quand même très très mal placé
c'est marrant que winter dans le chat au
même moment quoi
incroyable
et ceux qui continuent à graines ce
match ce qui continue à bien jouer
donc tout droit tour C3 on peut imaginer
je pense qu'il essaie de changer un peu
des pièces regagner la colonne C
fois j'utilise pour ce travail
il y a pas de découverte c'est pas
cavalier
donc je peux faire fonder 3 mais je
pense que la base l'idée c'est qu'elle
veut faire ça même si il est vrai
qu'après tour C3 peut-être que les Noirs
vont faire un collant de fou des deux
pour essayer de chasser la tour et
forcer un échange le tour là haut
il y a eu pour C3 F4
et soit qui viennent déjà quatre ans je
pense que si un joueur qui qui a besoin
des
de vos
[Musique]
vous encouragements c'est plutôt hargnan
pourtant
alors moi perso
perso je suis plus fan à rognan
mais je pense que so va gagner voilà
c'est pas une surprise mais je pense que
dans ces formats là
sont est meilleur que
caronial mais comme joueur je préfère un
Rognac parce que c'est un joueur qui est
quand même plus créatif et j'aime bien
ce côté moi ce côté un peu créatif le
spectacle je préfère
pareil
là le score en plus la position on voit
que saut et ben il a une minute d'avance
à la pendule et la minute qui peut quand
même changer des choses parce que même
ça reste solide et ben on peut se
tromper avec les avec les blancs les
noirs sont quand même plus actifs en
Europe qui est plus actif
c'est vraiment intello dans c'est ça
ouais non mais c'est vraiment deux
joueurs de joueurs qui qui se passait
bien du monde c'est clair ce joueur 8e
de finale c'est quand même
ça montre un petit peu le
[Musique]
un petit peu le
la complexité un petit peu de tournoi
quoi
tellement fort quoi
quand tu joues en 8e arrogant
il est quand même très fort
alors que je trouve qu'il y a un match
qui est un peu plus ouvert c'était
Sarana contre Sarine
c'est un peu plus ouvert mais ça ring il
est extrêmement fort en blitz sur
internet donc il est considéré comme
comme un joueur qui qui est peut-être
plus dangereux que certains donc
d'autres joueurs
moi j'aime bien Aaron j'ai toujours
trouvé cool
très sympathique
je suis retrouvé très sympa
et 5
il y a plus de temps ça commence à être
difficile pour la qui peut arriver
[Musique]
où il est possible dans tous les formats
chaque point compte
tour des trois jouets
et abandon
encore une fois un rognan ouais c'est
vraiment difficile
c'est vraiment difficile les joueurs qui
enchaînent et ça fait 5 1 maintenant
pour pour
[Musique]
de
la forme de chacun malheureusement
n'est pas à l'abri de pas être en forme
de mal jouer dans une compétition
ça peut ça peut arriver
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait un
truc
bon on peut pas deviner que rien ne va
se faire
laminer comme ça c'est quand même un
trash
après je pense qu'il peut revenir il
peut revenir à rognan il suffit qu'il
gagne une ou deux parties
et essayer de se mettre dans le dans le
truc
donc à trois a été joué B4
[Musique]
yes à pied prog
c'est une blague que je pense a dû être
faite un milliard de fois
et
on va garder celui-là quand même
mvl joue le vendredi 8
vendredi 8 septembre
si vous voulez l'heure exacte je peux
vous la donner
l'heure exacte
mvl d'ailleurs je vous dis n'importe
quoi
je vous dis n'importe quoi en
plus il joue pas du tout le 8 hein le 8
c'est à dire ça excusez-moi le 8 ça lit
résa des jours contre André kine à 19h
mais mvl et je contrecoupage le 11 à
14h30
voilà
c'est le 11 que je vais me réel à 14h30
G4 envoyer par a rognan ça fait plaisir
les pièces qui vont arriver à l'attaque
du Raban moi je suis clairement
clairement pour pour
Harmonia dans ce match
le 8 c'est la fin ok ouais
je me souviens une partie
il y avait une partie très connue aussi
so Wesley contre contre
Nakamura ou le roi de sceau était parti
se faire mater je crois en G6
avec les Blancs et brosse à très
longtemps et c'est une partie officielle
en partie classique partie lente et je
pense contre un joueur comme ça qui est
qui est très
très solide comme ça je pense c'est pas
une mauvaise idée de jouer des
pollutions comme est indien
je peux être neutre ou pas moi je porte
l'événement quand c'est un Français qui
joue je suis pour le français
là je préfère le joueur à rogner un je
trouve que c'est un joueur en tout cas
que je que je préfère en termes de style
et je préfère
stream plus tard une ronde de saut
apparemment
[Musique]
on défend suffisamment de fois mais
après c'est pas le cas de placer les
pièces
encore à part ça
pas évident à la potion comme celui d'un
chez les Blancs
F6 flotto à F8 un jour un truc comme ça
et c'est vraiment on a remis toutes les
pièces à l'attaque ça pourrait être
vraiment
pas mal du tout il reste 25 minutes
dans ce dans cette portion de temps
ça ressemble à gagnant mais en fait
j'étais fort quand même pas mal
je défends bien et ton roi il est quand
même assez ouvert donc à tout moment tu
perds G4 et tu fais partie
c'est pas si sûr que tu gagnes
quand ce gagne c'est solidaire c'est ça
pion qui pousse tu la douche cette trêve
tu l'as d'où cette trèfle pion qui
pousse tu me fais peur là ne me dis pas
que c'est ne me dis pas que c'est chez
un certain thé vert
salut
je pense c'est rien à voir c'est juste
pas de sens en fait
je crois que c'est juste pas de sens qui
pousse ok je préfère ça je préfère ça
parce qu'il y a une chanson qui tourne
depuis
depuis quelques jours et
oui j'ai compris mais au-delà du jeu de
mots il y a un autre truc qui tourne au
sujet de Tirana
en Albanie et t'as pas la rêve mais du
coup t'as pas fait exprès mais du coup
tu m'as mis le doute c'est bien quand
même dommage 5 oui c'est un coup qu'on a
envie de faire quand même dommage 5
faire attention à ce que je peux pas
juste manger j'ai 4 du style ça ça et ça
attention avec le Caval il est pas
stable en F3 c'est pas si facile
de retourner les choses avec les noirs
ça peut complètement se retourner avec
la tour qui paraît déranger 1 le roi
noir qui peut être très faible parce que
maintenant j'ai fait
4 le cavalion c'est pas trop il va aller
un objet qui va s'ouvrir
mais on va partir d'ici je vais manger
là je vais manger là
le fou qui était de nouveau bien
cavaler prend un cadre alors attendez là
c'est hyper compliqué
tout en haut
pourquoi que se passe-t-il
là c'est je comprends rien il y a tout
en prise il y a 50 prises sacrées sacré
en prison l'idée c'est avec les
cavaliers pour pouvoir manger le fou
éclatour d'un project tempo ça va trop
vite si je prends là il y a qu'à valider
comme ça
tout en prise se reprend je dois avoir
comment ça se passe se reprendre
même pas si clair si on reprend et
comment ça joue
c'est la partie on va le voir on reprend
F4 d'un point dans ma page 5
on voit ici
ça va suffire
ça m'a l'air mince quand même comme
chose manque G6 roi là
ouais c'est chaud c'est chaud et aussi
fou aussi que j'ai complètement raté qui
gagne la dame mais combien de pièces
pour la dame j'ai une tour de cavaliers
ça fait quand même beaucoup de pièces
et j'ai l'impression que Cameronian est
très mal encore une fois
si je mange la dame
tu as pas cette pièce pour mater en fait
et c'est moi qui vais te mettre en fait
c'est moi qui vais ramener les pièces à
tort ici mat
séduire parce que là pour le corps il
avait vraiment fait des choses
il est vraiment réussi à être créé
mais ça tient pas il y a trop trop de
pièces pour pour ça les joueurs qui sont
capables de calculer à une rapidité
impressionnante il y avait toutes les
pièces en prises et pour eux c'est
facile ça joue vite ça joue vite et les
bons coups c'est juste complètement
horrible salut
en plus il y a ça ok horrible trop trop
dur c'est pas son jour aujourd'hui à
un petit peu
la 6 1 en ce match
si jamais vu
c'est un masque qui est censé quand même
être être extrêmement
complexe extrêmement serré les joueurs
quand j'ai même niveau c'est kif
c'est kif et pourtant 6 1 6 1 pour pour
Wesley et ça fait ouais ça fait 5
victoires d'affiléen pour ça
ça commençait par deux nulles là ça fait
5 parties d'affilée que à rognon perd
donc ça se passe très très mal enfin
environ 40 minutes
qui perd
non et pas moins mais ça peut arriver tu
es pas dedans
la jauge qui a encore buggé
c'est juste que là il est pas en forme
il est sur un mauvais rêche mais c'est
pas du tout parce que là il fait
mauvaise prestation qui est moins fort à
ce niveau là ils sont vraiment pas
pareil et franchement il y a 5 points
d'écart c'est quand même beaucoup mais
ok il peut revenir il peut revenir à 5
points c'est c'est pas si énorme que ça
c'est pas ce qui est pas comme ça après
il y a une heure de Blitz et une
demi-heure de Bullet franchement si je
fais plus de plus de en blitz ça prend
Bullet je force un peu sur mon + 3 c'est
de largement remontable largement
remontable
et joueurs qui sont du même niveau à peu
près donc c'est tu peux faire enfin
complètement raté un format comme ça en
5 + 1 et remonter après
mais c'est vrai que 5 + 5
ça pardon que 6 1 le score c'est pas si
c'est pas si
[Musique]
c'est dur je dis pas qu'il va le faire
c'était juste que c'est possible
le ventre pour Wesley
non
il est il est
d'humeur blague en ce moment
[Musique]
il a déjà fait une blague hier sur sur
le match la Camorra you
mais oui
[Musique]
belle partie faire douter Wesley et
revenir
je pense c'est le coup un peu du mec qui
tilt
plus G3 quand même
et profiter un petit peu plus tôt du
l'affaiblissement sur le long terme sur
le roi
mais tu laisses pas emporter pas ton
style
[Musique]
ne mange pas en G5 s'il te plaît
je regarde pas j'écoute le son du coup
on se calme un petit peu
je suis pas sûr que mon GSM fait une
bonne solution comptez quand tu es à -5
dans le score je comprends que tu vas
revenir au score mais c'est plutôt un
coup j'ai envie de dire de tills quoi
allez faut prendre un tour de tourner un
essayer de faire un truc
on joue on joue aux échecs
Albanie
parce que là vraiment il faut qu'il
remonte au score c'est important
qui pourra pas revenir au score
immédiatement bien sûr qu'il va ça va
très très long on sait pas s'il va
réussir mais il faut en tout cas qui
commence à marquer des points dans ce
dans ce match
qu'avec les deux
[Musique]
à avoir à l'arrêt
tout mon gîte à avoine à la relève
c'est à cause
d'une certaine personne
il y a une il y a une musique qui est
sortie en fait
mais si vous voulez on pourra en parler
on pourra en parler si vous voulez
sur ma chaîne ça serait un peu mieux
demain je vais sûrement sûrement stream
je vais sûrement string sur ma chaîne
demain
donc n'hésitez pas à me leur demander ce
qu'ils ont question sur
ceux qui ont une question sur
[Musique]
l'origine
vous êtes très à 6
j'arrive pas à manger là il y avait des
prendre tout le temps
non il y a pas du tout karaoké c'est
rien à voir
tout ça
absolument rien à voir
ok prise prise qui a value E3 et puis sa
structure un peu plus faible que la
mienne mais quand même une bonne chance
de devenir amis ici je pense je vois pas
trop le problème pour
pour
ça ici
je pense ça va faire nul
si vous voulez la blague aussi j'ai une
blague aussi hein
il a 6 points
fourchette
monsieur
4 et enfin un truc comme ça
il a 6 pour l'instant donc
à saucisse
fatigué je commence à dire n'importe
quoi
à choix peut-être H4
je sais pas si j'ai des cases de retour
pour mon cavalier
je peux revenir en arrière pas sûr
t'inquiète pas les places seront
elles seront elles sont pas très chères
ils sont accessibles à tout le monde
4 ou 3 c'est 4 mois
sont un peu mieux vous voyez que ce pion
en C5 s'il était pas dans c'est 5 c'est
là où là pas de faiblesse j'avais pas de
problème pour les noirs
et du coup bah c'est pas facile
pas facile
et quand même de belles chances de nul
mais
[Musique]
en pratique A4 sur les trois C4
en fait
qui est
fou c'est cette je mange le pion bien
j'ai trois et qui va manger
parce que je mange là il y a quand même
pas ça à cause de reprend G3 cavaillage
4 par contre une belle idée le pion sera
perdu
de trucs imbécile je comprends pas c'est
bizarre ce que tu me dis
la position est très compliquée il y a
20 secondes chacun
et
à rejoindre beaucoup mieux cavalier ici
cavalière 4 peut-être un des trois
pardon comment j'ai F4 ou C5
en passant
comment tu prends en passant avec si
j'ai pas de pion à côté
[Musique]
ça a l'air
ça a l'air pas possible donc ici Caval
F4 et je crois que c'est une
maintenant
on va réussir à manger
le pion B6 donc attention
il y a ça en l'air encore
on voit ici ça a l'air gagné cette
histoire je fous des 8 peut-être encore
pour résister
il faut passer le fou par derrière
foulard Fulla mais attention qu'il y a
roi qui peut venir ici
on défend et fou ici peut-être pour
pousser là c'est compliqué on voit la
jauge qui change d'avis à chaque coup et
B5 qui arrive malheureusement c'est pas
gagné horrible
et pattes
horrible horrible horrible horrible même
quand on est gagnant on gagne pas c'est
difficile pour
pour ce match très très dur
et du coup il a il a SAUCISSE et demi
allez si c'est demi un demi
et j'ai quatre fous de 5 de la semaine
qui est très très théorique
elle dessin qu'elle
H 3 kmh 6
trucs
un petit peu il est moins actif beaucoup
moins c'est vrai
c'est vrai un peu quand elle était en
top niveau toute ta vie
c'est dur des fois
dans le mou mais bon un jour la canne
toujours
ça reste un excellent joueur
par ce pion en D4 qui va être perdu
alors souvent on peut donner pour ouvrir
ce fou
attention qu'il y a 5 c'est pas possible
comment je continue
il donne une pièce c'est grave ou pas
donc tu reves 8 Triki cette petit rock
sur la prise de la petite F3
quelle tristesse
elle est tout revu
en tout cas ça fait réfléchir
il a fait petit rock et prise fou F3 je
pensais il faut F3 faire attention il va
y avoir des coups de cavalu à 3 mais ça
a l'air chaud
pas trop si un jour elle va réussir à
ressortir les ventes
on n'est pas sûr quoi
d'avoir un peu ce qui se passe mais
trois je pense quasi au pays de faire ça
toujours pas ça tu perds
et tu vas finir par la paire il y a tout
en prise
c'est chaud en tout cas en tout cas
reliant
la chose qui aime pas comme ce qu'il a
fait
donc tu regardes
beaucoup toujours
sur son site
accroupi sur son Sanchez
elle se comprend pas c'est comment il
fait pour jouer repensé compte ici so
Wesley
F3 il y avait cavalu E3 je pense encore
apparemment c'est pas bon du tout et je
sais pas ce qu'il fallait jouer
apparemment c'est deux était très très
bien
mais bon c'est des raisons un peu
obscures
où j'ai trois a l'air quand même mettre
un coup humain
et c'est un problème sur mon cavalier
quand même que je songe à le à le bouger
mais je le mets où parce que même
qu'elle va aller au 5 il y a du F3 dans
l'air il y a des trucs comme ça c'est un
peu peur pour ma tour pas facile même
aussi le pion des cartes qui va être en
prise la tour qui est un peu enfermé
aussi il a joué F5 tiens hop il laisse
tout ouvert
sur F3 il y a toujours Cavalo 3 sur fou
F3
incroyable qui joue D3 de Gibraltar
et après la prise prise regardez la 2
pions donc un passé en Détroit
sur le pion F2 c'est chaud il me faut H6
peut être aussi une possibilité j'aime
bien ce qu'il a à faire en pratique
il joue il joue l'attaque je trouve ça
beau je trouve ça beau
je crois que c'est un accident de
voiture il me semble
c'était il y a quelques années mais
maintenant il est de nouveau quelqu'un
d'autre et il est il est heureux mais
bon c'est dur
c'est dur il y en a bien des fois ça
tient pas grand chose donc j'ai pas
envie de vous casser le moral
pas du tout mais là vous en parlez donc
du coup je réponds un peu mais
donc là je suspecte peut-être ah ça
marche pas j'ai pas le temps de faire
Dame des 7
ça prend 4 et j'ai pas compris cavalier
F3 fourchette tu manges manges attaque
la tour et j'ai pas envie de faire ça
mais il y a des idées qui peuvent
arriver comme ça
un jour peut-être
donc tout c'est la partie c'est pas
qu'on va continuer ici avec
[Musique]
avec les noirs
puis il est important je peux pas le
perdre
5 forcer alors 5 c'est
triste quand même de reculer
mais bon
[Musique]
je pensais à faire ça et ça mais bon
pareil tu prends la fourchette
et après tu prendras là mon roi il est
safe
conception tu le perds après tu parleras
à lui tu parleras à lui je ferai F3
tranquille une fois que j'aurai tout
mangé et cavalier F3 a été joué par par
even prise et maintenant attention
est-ce que vous y croyez moi pas trop ça
déjà juste
tout retro a été joué dans 17 il va
juste manger là je pense
ça prend
sur ça il y a ça si je fais tout là
je me sens
les joueurs qui voient tout à une
vitesse c'est des machines c'est des
grosses machines il y avait tout
et qui va essayer de faire un truc mais
bon ça va être ça va être pris
il voit tout il voit tout
instantanément les joueurs
merci beaucoup pour ton petit lien néo
sur le chat vous savez que je passais
maître international il y a un mois et
j'ai fait une vidéo
expliquant ma dernière partie la partie
qui m'a fait passer mettre international
donc sur Youtube donc c'est pour ceux
qui n'ont pas vu vous avez le lien sur
le chat avec Neo qui nous le partage
[Musique]
j'en profite de parler de cette vidéo
YouTube n'hésitez pas aussi à vous
abonner
aux différentes chaînes là vous avez bon
le lien avec la vidéo de ma chaîne perso
mais donc n'hésitez pas déjà vous
abonner à la chaîne perso mais aussi la
chaîne Youtube de cheescom pour ceux qui
nous regardent là en ce moment sur sur
chestcom FR sur Youtube n'hésitez pas à
nous à nous à nous follow c'est gratuit
et puis c'est pas de rester au contact
avec nous dès qu'on a un événement dès
qu'on est en live etc et là vous saurez
tout ce qu'on fait
vous serez au courant de tout n'hésitez
pas en tout cas nous follow sur Youtube
ou sur twitch ceux qui sont présents
aussi qui sont pas encore follow de la
chaîne
suivez la chaîne vous serez au courant
de tout ce qui se passe sur la chaîne
merci option qui pousse
et là du coup ouais cavaler le 3
c'est un peu les pièces sur le roi
donc
on garde les pièces on bouge plus
tout
le fou contre le cavalier
[Musique]
ici
ça va tourner mais ici saut il parlera
pas
je vous garantis que c'est pas du genre
de la maison de rater
[Musique]
une partie comme ça ça va être un
bandeau d'ailleurs très vite dame là et
cavalier
abandon
et c'est terminé pour ce 7 j'avais pas
vu qu'on était arrivé qu'on était arrivé
à la fin du timer alors on a du coup on
a ceux qui mène 7 et demi à 1 et demi
dans ce premier dans ce premier set
c'est absolument incroyable le niveau
des parties
difficiles en tout cas aussi pour
aroniade qui est à -6 donc -6 c'est
difficile
à remonter mais c'est jamais impossible
alors il me faudrait vraiment qu'il soit
sur une nouvelle lancée là en 3 + 1 et
qu'il arrive à distancer en tout cas au
moins dans la partie Blitz 3+1 pour
après faire all-in ambulette donc
tout reste encore possible bien sûr
avantage à relire avantage chaud dans ce
match
donc on va faire une petite courte pub
de environ 5 minutes et je reviens
pour la portion 3 + 1
3 + 1 2 ce mal je vous dis à tout de
suite
[Musique]
si je trouve
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
championnat du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechesse
ou les titles
tuesday.com/aventure tous les plus
grands tournois des chèques il se
déroulent en présentiel ou en ligne
vivez comprenez en direct les parties
des meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec
les commentaires en français de nos
experts notre moteur d'analyse
l'explorateur d'ouverture et les tables
bases retrouvez toutes les infos
essentielles comme le programme les
horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats des comptes rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition aux
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chains.com/avent ou c'est bien sur le
site internet que sur nos applications
iOS et Android pour vivre votre passion
comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
je suis de retour dans ce match là où
les trois plus un vont commencer on va
voir une heure de Blitz 3 + 1
prochainement là avec une pause
normalement pause très rapide qui va
avoir lieu au milieu du temps
réglementaire
donc une demi-heure
deux trois puissances suivi de une pause
de 5 minutes pour les joueurs
et une demi-heure de 3 + 1
avant de faire une nouvelle pause et
d'arriver en bullette et d'enchaîner la
demi-heure de Bullet
donc c'est parti qui vont commencer dans
un instant on a 15 secondes de délai je
crois que les caméras 15 secondes c'est
pas grand chose mais il y a un léger
petit délai
et ceux qui est parti sans fermer
je ne sais pas ce qu'il est parti faire
mais
ça sert de manière très vite je pense
que là on va reprendre
les parties je vais regarder un peu mon
truc là ici
[Musique]
ok en fait je vois que sur le slack il y
a eu des joueurs qui ont le même
problème que moi j'ai eu au tout début
vous savez qu'on n'avait pas la partie
qui s'était lancé bizarre mais du coup
j'étais pas le seul dans ce problème là
[Musique]
allez Wesley
qui arrive qui va s'installer
enfin pouvoir commencer cette deuxième
portion en trois plus un donc là les
vannes qui va absolument se reprendre
les von qui qui
est mené 7,5
gros score en faveur de saut donc il va
falloir qu'il se reprenne très très vite
en main
ça va être difficile mais
quand même 6 points comme ça
jamais facile
j'avais facile pour
pour ce genre là on va venir d'un retard
assez conséquent
difficile pour le mental je pense qu'il
peut le faire à rogner franchement c'est
un joueur qui qui est revenu qui est
revenu de loin plein de fois
je suis d'accord que le format il est un
peu pénible à ce niveau-là c'est vrai
que quand c'est one way ça veut dire
qu'on vraiment il y a un gros écart
entre les joueurs et ben je pendant
trois heures ensemble ça peut être long
ça peut être long
on a vu hier Nakamura qui se baladait
complètement contre contre
ce match là normalement c'était pas
prévu qu'il y a un grand écart comme ça
c'était un des matchs peut-être qui
devait être les plus
les plus chauds les plus
les plus égaux on va dire et
[Musique]
je suis un peu surpris de ce même très
surpris du temps
ça aurait pas dû être comme ça peut-être
un 5 4
4 4 on aurait pu être
plus logique mais en tout cas
je suis quand même c'est du Blitz c'est
du Blitz qui met là on est quand même
deux des meilleurs joueurs du monde
même si ceux il faut pas perdre il peut
perdre des parties à rogner en face ici
comment faire car pas encore bien réussi
à le faire mais
mais il est capable en tout cas de
revenir
ouais je pense qu'il y a un trop gros
écart ça devrait pouvoir s'arrêter mais
malheureusement bon ce match là en plus
il y a un règlement qui fait que vous
savez qu'il y avait pris si tu passes
tel ou tel ou telle étape et ben tu
gagnes bah les frais de prix sont
différentes mais à la fin
si jamais tu as arrêté un match parce
que tu en as marre parce que tu utilises
parce que c'est trop dur et ben
tout simplement
je crois que tu il t'enlève un
pourcentage je crois de du prix que tu
aurais dû avoir par exemple imaginons
que je suis pas là actuellement le
perdant prend 3000 dollars par exemple
le tournoi et ben tu
prends que 50% entre les prix
donc l'idée c'est vraiment d'aller
jusqu'au bout même pour le faire play
par rapport par rapport à tout et bah il
faut aller jusqu'au bout même si tu es
mené 20-0 il fallait jusqu'au bout il y
avait un match je crois que c'était
Nakamura qui avait joué contre Houilles
fan donc la numéro 1 mondial et le monde
de l'époque et le score ça avait été un
truc mais ultra sévère
c'est un peu du score mais c'était un
truc de style 20 et demi
à un demi ou à deux et demi c'est comme
ça le score final
là c'est ouf là c'était juste
stratosphérique quand tu vois Nakamura
et où Yifan malgré tout quasiment 2700 €
et bon c'était un peu humilié quoi donc
à un moment donné j'ai envie de dire
qu'on est trop de cas les matchs sont
pas trop d'intérêts quoi mais ce match
là il est censé être très fort
censé être très chaud et là c'était demi
un demi c'est la grosse surprise en tout
cas du jour ceux qui a qui a gagné un
moment donné à cinq parties d'affilée
on va faire une huile et d'en regagner
une derrière donc toujours qui s'apprête
à jouer à commencer le Blitz en trois
plus une
ça commence moi j'ai pas encore les
parties
le lancement de la partie
moi j'ai encore rien
ça fait quand même un peu long la pause
c'est un peu long la pause
et ça va enchaîné donc une heure deux
trois plus un et c'est parti
avec Levan un royaume Canet blanc dans
ce début de match
et là il va falloir que l'argent
qui vient de commencer son cours
alors il joue une sorte de lapine avec
fou d'attention de cavalier prend 4 dans
4 échec d'apprendre à 4 c'est le gros
piège de la ligne et c'est comme tout à
l'heure il joue toujours pareil alors
pour l'instant il n'a pas obtenu grand
chose dans l'ouverture
à rognan donc ça m'étonne qui continue à
jouer
la même ligne à chaque fois
il laisse toujours cavalier de 4 ans il
laisse le four en prise donc
et maintenant on va sûrement faire P4 au
prochain coup
avec les Blancs
moi je suis pas fan c'est pollution on a
un peu bloqué avec nos pièces c'est pas
comment continuer
prise ok ça me parle et c'est 4 là il y
a des idées avec cavalier B6 prendre la
paire de fou mais aussi qu'elle va les
bêtises pour je cavaler des cinq et
après se créer un pion passé qui sera
protégé d'ailleurs
reste une idée la jauge qui a encore
complètement buggé
qui avait ces quatre jouets
cavalier des six simples
B5 du coup est un coup
B5 ça la partie qui avait B6 obligé là
je prends un fou j'ai deux fous
c'est quand même quelque chose de bien
très bien j'ai du mal à penser que les
Blancs ont un avantage aussi
je trouve que c'est assez bizarre quand
même ce petit choix d'ouverture par les
vannes parce qu'il a pas obtenu grand
chose dans cette position qu'avec les
deux peut-être il veut jouer F4
peut-être il veut se garder autre chose
aussi parce qu'il y a quatre qui peut
arriver en cas de mouvement du pion je
sais qu'à ce cas pour le cavalier le
retour
donc H5 bien joué j'ai l'impression sur
F4 il y a un coût Marlo qui est fou H6
pour venir clouer ce petit pion F c'est
l'idée je pense de c'est l'idée de H5 de
pouvoir revenir et maintenant ces quatre
attention quand tu prends là tu perds
aussi le cuir le 4
en tout cas c'est si on laisse les Noirs
échangeant des trois j'aurai un pion
faible en C3 qui va devenir faible tout
le temps apprise par exemple
ok là je mange des trois par le fou ou
par la dame
tout va vite probablement
continue un peu et tout à 8 défendra 6
et les blancs obtenus l'ouverture de la
colonne A4 comme possibilité tapez un
jour sur
le long terme le pion c'est 3 c'est
toujours un peu une faiblesse
genre un peu la faiblesse il y a eu des
quatre
on se débarrasse de la faiblesse je
prends qu'un ça peut aussi être chaud
attention à toutes les pièces en prises
d'Amla peut-être tu prends ici sur mon
jeu en B4
il faut réussir à brûler le cavalier
pour s'arrêter jouer
tous les 5 peut être aussi les derniers
jours
en temps
[Musique]
l'idée de Wesley et c'est pour ça qu'il
y a eu cavalier B3 pour empêcher cavaler
des quatre
on retourne B8 clouage ok on donne le
pion dans le pion en 4 ça risque de tout
échanger ça tu as pensé un
ton français
et là vous voyez
tout qui s'échange
complètement échanger et ça ça va faire
mieux
donc c'est l'idée de saut qui propose et
changer toutes les pièces dans une
minute 10 pour les vannes contre 50
secondes pour Wesley avec un score qui
va obliger les vannes à prendre vraiment
les devants dans ce match
avec 6 points de retard il faut
commencer vraiment à
marquer des points
et là je me vois mal partout quand même
les problèmes je pense qu'il va falloir
tout manger peut-être qu'il faut jouer
de la nuit là ici peut-être que le mieux
c'est de la nuit
va finir par manger et ouais
comme position au moins ça joue ça reste
ça reste compliqué ce petit pion à 5 qui
peut un jour être prenable attention ouh
là là faut prendre un cadre T3 on va
manger en 1
niveau pièce
c'est peut-être ça
c'est hyper chaud et tout je veux parler
jouer cette position et d'un premier 4
qui va être le coup quand je mangeais je
perds
et au final écouter il a réussi à
récupérer un petit pion la rouage cette
forcée on te reprend tout bien sûr je
prends la dame gratos donc H7 et j'ai
pas tactique je crois qu'il me font qui
me font gagner et prise de la reprise là
haut time C4
malgré le pion de plus c'est vrai il y a
quand même reposer ça a une belle tête
de faire match nul cette histoire d'un
point F7 serait cuiller d'un échec
il faut le 5 mais je crois que j'arrive
les blancs qui peuvent un peu un peu
forcé au final peut-être avec le
problème qui a sur le 15 blanche j'y
crois pas du tout mais
[Musique]
voilà ça va faire 1100 la première 4 je
pense qu'il y a aucune chance
il y a aucune chance
de passer toute leur poser je pense
qu'il y a aucune chance à moins de
perdre autant
la pendule dans F3
j'ai déjà qu'ici
je vois pas du tout comment ça peut
mal tourner un pion
mais il a quand même aussi ce qui peut
filer un jour à dame mais je pense que
la nul va être signé il y a aucun moyen
de pouvoir
s'en tirer ok nul dans cette partie
on va revenir ici
mettre les points
donc ça fait
8% et 2 pour harmonial donc les nuls ça
arrange jamais vraiment
ça rend jamais rien les nuls
parce que
vous voyez là
pour faire nul qui a perdu 9 minutes du
temps qu'il a il a en tout encore 50
minutes en blitz et 30 minutes en Bullet
donc chaque nul et ben il est hyper
habitant donc il faut vraiment commencer
à mettre les points etc
je te mets en charge de tout ce qui est
prédiction
si tu veux t'amuser un petit peu si tu
veux faire le muse je crois qu'il y
avait des joueurs dans le chat qui
[Musique]
qui était un pas contre faire des
prédictions sur le score un peu des
joueurs moi hier j'ai fait dans le match
Nakamura contre Ding pardon contre Ayou
et ben j'ai fait pas mal de prédiction
sur le score de chaque partie donc
chaque partie que se passe-t-il et
créatif soit créatif mon ami
fous des quatre
plein de choses en prise ici alors vous
aussi a été joué dame j'ai 5 ça alors
quand même tendu je pense que petit Rock
sera possible
E54 je pense c'est bien joué à
cavalucate qui pourrait venir sur tes
cadres intéressantes plus tard qu'avec
des cinq moi j'aime bien cavalier E4 par
exemple
j'aime bien les blancs dans ces
positions
dans ces positions
bien les blancs généralement ça se
positionner 4
essayer de profiter un petit peu de la
ou d'un E3 pour filer de la colonne des
bouger le fou faire passer les tours le
cavalier
il y a vraiment un monde où les blancs
arrivent un peu à travailler à faire des
choses même fou c'est 5 c'est une idée
pour changer de foucassement
mais les Noirs ont la part de fou et sur
le long terme les cartes blanches
peuvent être très très fortes donc c'est
les potions compliquées
mais justement ça a préféré tout le
temps les blancs dans cette position
j'aime beaucoup ces pauses
dames 3
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui va être joué
B5 ok moi j'aime bien ça là
bouge un truc
sur la
quand même
[Musique]
il y aura bien tranquille
je pense qu'ils ont un problème dans la
potion d'Evan
je pense qu'il y a vraiment un problème
dans ma position et ça sent pas bon avec
une minute devant la pendule et escorte
[Musique]
ça sent très très mauvais pour les
tu as encore le temps
[Musique]
ça peut lui prendre deux semaines donc
le temps direct
en vrai c'est très très dur comme
production
très bien
grosse souffrance pour pouvoir revenir
dans ce match
grosse souffrance grosse torture
qui est
très très grosse souffrance d'amour
c'est trop bien
dans
et c'est abondant on va changer de thème
on va rajouter un petit point
à Wesley ça fait 9 9 7 9 2 1 ça fait
maintenant plus 7 sur le score avec le
temps qui s'écoule ça tient difficile
mais vraiment difficile pour rognan donc
vraiment ce qui va réussir à revenir
dans le score et puis ça va plus c'est
dur moralement pour le joueur
l'ancien joueur arménien
parce que franchement
c'est dur
[Musique]
c'est extrêmement dur ce qui se passe
des trois jouets
ah oui
je crois que c'est le quatrième joueur
qui a eu le plus de temps
parce qu'il y a 45
numéro 2
c'est Kasparov
numéro 3
[Musique]
avec 2035
quand même
c'est chaud c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un gros hello puis bien
sûr palmarès
il a tout gagné
[Musique]
un V alors certes
il y a eu qui
il y a eu un
peu de 2008 il y a une
je sais plus dans quel ordre
il y a eu aussi diri
mais après un tube 35
j'ai pas le classement en tête là
mais je dirais que n'a qu'à doit être 5
et mvs6 ML7
[Musique]
et 8 ça passe tout de suite ça doit être
peut-être un Guiri ou un truc comme ça
je sais pas si je me trompais
alors les prédictions sont placées
[Musique]
score de aronyan en trois plus un
ça c'est pas typique en vrai c'est close
5 c'est sauts
et 6 ça doit être pas la fin
et cette nouvelle
9e 10 à ma mère aussi ah ouais ok
lui je l'avais oublié ma main
ok ok bon après ça c'est les records les
records de record hello mais à l'époque
où Topalov il avait Stella c'était pas
l'époque de Maxime non plus c'était à
l'époque c'était quand même plus
prestigieuse je pense même si ça reste
moins de 3 3 ou plus
a été joué on va voir manger F5 je pense
pas envie de faire ce fou quand même
c'est reposer mais j'ai encore ma jauge
qui déconne il est mieux mais pas plus
10 non plus
il y a un truc pour le blanc mais son
pion est là
c'est
favorise l'attaque le premier qui arrive
à attaquer
par un plat j'aime bien me G3 mettre le
fond ici et essayer de menacer les
petites choses pour être cool
qu'il a aussi 2008 je crois oui oui il a
eu sa période assez ils ont tous leur
parler en fait
sauf
il y a eu l'heure qu'ils n'ont pas eu il
était très proche il y a eu Raja bof qui
a eu 2007
99,6 je crois Raja bof il y a eu aussi
un jour que j'aimais beaucoup c'était
comment il s'appelle ce Russe là
un Russe qui jouait
à 2007 80 morosevic merci
de quelque chose je crois
deux joueurs non il est trop loin par
contre
c'est une position où
c'est assez égal mais les blancs peuvent
pousser
et il y a plus de temps pour saut
c'est intéressant pour pouvoir revenir
cette partie aussi qui est intéressant
genre
[Musique]
trop de mettre là il y aura tout reprend
ici voilà ce matin
pas me permettre pour l'instant de
manger la fou prend c'est une menace ou
pas
de menace
dame
en défense
osselait fou
de jouer
et l'avoir ce que parfois
[Musique]
ça a été joué brillant c'est pas un
matelas
j'ai pas un match j'ai pas un truc comme
ça il y a ça
ça un truc comme ça mais bon c'est long
je sais pas s'il y a mieux les 25
secondes pour les vannes
tu trouveras
ça le fait sourire
par contre là après faut être fuite il
va m'en sourire je crois
il a moins sourire
il a sauvé juste avant le karma qui est
rattrapé so Wesley qui va offrir sa
première victoire à rognan après 4 nuls
franchement c'est mérité allez c'est le
début de la remonter
c'est le début de la remontada chez Les
Vans harmonyan cette partie allez
il faut il faut remonter
à on continue donc ceux qui ont un
solide pour essayer de changer les
choses et à Royan qui joue B5 qui joue
vraiment initiative qui joue le gros
combat
à ta parier tu as pas aimé
toujours en train de parler
très comparer
mais très mauvais parieur très gros mais
très mauvais par ailleurs notre ami
une grosse grosse tension sur tout le
centre des blancs
donc la prise par exemple je vais
reprendre et dessin qu'elle a seulement
maintenant qui prend le centre
donc la jauge qui est un peu un problème
des fois
il y a eu prise c'est la partie en plus
c'est incroyable
prise
joueur du Top 20 monde
orchestre confondues le plus constant
sur 10 ans et l'eau
[Musique]
et 70 toute la nuit toute sa vie
je pense que le numéro 1
je sais pas je sais pas
le gros centre de leven
généralement ça fait un pion pour avoir
cette position pour voir ce pour voir
cette position avec les noirs
prendre sa deuxième victoire d'affilée
ce serait quand même
ce serait très beau franchement
ce serait beau
à trois avec les jouets est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous vous croyez aux chances
de baroniales est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il peut revenir est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il peut gagner ce match
ça ouvre quand même
je suis le seul je suis le seul à croire
encore aux chances d'araignées
non mais si il arrive à rester à -3 ça
veut dire revenir à 6 9 et encore c'est
gagné peut-être qu'après en Bullet
on va voir je pense ça va dépenser de
cette partie là si il gagne cette partie
ça fait deux parties d'affilée
franchement
mais c'est vrai moi je suis l'optimiste
généralement je suis vraiment un
optimiste donc
mais
c'est vrai que j'ai c'est dur il va
falloir qu'ils manque de l'argent
mais bon
ah oui c'est vrai que c'est ça c'est dur
en fait le problème c'est qu'il y a trop
peu de temps quoi il reste plus qu'une
heure
avec un
je suis d'accord avec toi Monster
machines mais pour Jean baumannfeld
vraiment tu as un pion de moi avec les
noirs et là t'as pas de pion de moi donc
c'est plutôt une bonne idée Tu as même
un peu plus
mais c'est une voiture un peu de ce type
là
salut GMP
S et j'ai paire de fou avec un pion
passé
donc il y a quelque chose de gains quand
même
prise B4 peut-être qui empêche de venir
ici avec
[Musique]
fais attention au blocage sur la carte
blanche aussi
compris qu'il faut que je joue vite
il est pris par le temps il faut
vraiment qu'il gagne le plus de parties
le plus vite possible
la H6 voilà voilà
[Musique]
trois là
un truc comme ça
c'est à quel point le roi c'est
important de le montant en finale
un point de russe
parce que pendant
la maison pendant que toutes les pièces
travaillent le roi c'est un leader le
roi il doit venir avec les pièces le roi
il doit aider les pièces à travailler
[Musique]
non mais soyez ultra solide
sauce
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un joueur qui peut qui
peut mettre à mal carcène Nakamura c'est
un joueur qui qui peut réussir à les
battre c'est là
c'est vraiment un joueur qui peut les
qui peut les battre
après bien sûr à rognon-dessous mais bon
c'est quand même un gros calibre
on fait parce qu'il va me laisser roi là
et mettre une Caballé ici
as-tu prends je pousse incroyable prise
pousse-pousse dans ma parole
allez magique et abandon direct boum on
repart deux parties d'affilée les gars
vous allez voir je vais faire mentir
qui est reparti qui va vraiment
déjà pour votre pari pour ceux qui ont
Paris moins donc c'est ce que je pense
de vous
et en plus il va tout gagner
il va tout gagner
allez plus qu'à - 5 je sais que c'est
beaucoup mais il est à deux victoires
d'affilée
ça faisait longtemps qu'il est pas gagné
de partir
et maintenant
des lancer et lancer la machine il est
chaud
après il y a encore un gros écart il y a
encore 5 points
mais s'il arrive à juste moi 3
bonbulette il commence la partie
boomigan plus de ouais c'est ça peut ça
peut jouer quoi ça peut jouer et Wesley
sur sa chaise de le truc là où il y a
pas de place je vous rappelle que que
Wesley il joue d'une manière assez
incroyable je sais pas si vous avez si
vous avez regardé dans quelles
conditions Wesley joue ça c'est
incroyable ces conditions il est tout le
temps tout le temps comme ça alors je
vous le montrer pour ceux qui le pour
ceux qui l'ont pas encore vu mais je
vais vous montrer l'arrière
il joue il est assez sur une chaise en
bois
il habite orateur sur une chaise d'ordi
et il a la souris qui est placé sur
l'ordinateur et il joue comme ça et il
est très rapide
et
à chaque speech il est pareil contre
pareil contre tout le monde joue pareil
et il est et il est c'est ouf comme si
il pouvait pas s'acheter une table c'est
incroyable
il est mieux ici ah oui le dos là ça va
ça va finir cette histoire mais du coup
je me dis bon toujours un petit peu
l'espoir à Rognac ambulette ou quoi il
se force non comme ça je sais pas il
aime
comme ça il a à moitié taré pour le coup
parce que bon il faut avoir envie quand
même de
jouer comme ça c'est quand même
[Musique]
je sais pas spécial quand même
est-ce que c'est cadence de style de jeu
est-ce que dans ces cadences le style de
jeu sur l'ensemble d'une des parties peu
palier oui oui tu peux bien sûr qu'il y
a plein il y a plein de Blender c'est du
bled ça va très très vite
il se passe beaucoup de choses il y a
aussi la fatigue il y a plein de choses
qui rentrent en jeu dans ce dans tous
ces formats c'est par là et tout
au monde
il sera
[Musique]
c'est clair je suis d'accord avec toi
mais bon je vais dans ces conditions
c'est quand même enfin c'est la c'est un
peu la punition quoi la première fois
que je l'ai vu faire ça je pensais que
il était pas chez lui et que c'était
vraiment
occasionnel que bon ben voilà quoi mais
en fait c'était tout le temps comme ça
donc ça c'est incroyable pour le coup
alors cavalier c'est 4 avec les jouets
tour B1
ça fait maintenant un moment que c'était
on a déjà parlé avant il y a eu des bars
mais il y a eu des problèmes ça
fédération et du coup il s'est dit que
il voulait changer parce qu'il avait
aucune aide de sa fédération
et j'aime bien encore au niveau des fois
la partie de l'evan qui a vachement
accéléré vous voyez il a une huile
d'avance à la pendule faut prendre
d'affiler les gars je vous dis trois
affiliés
pour venir gagner ce match ça serait
complètement incroyable ça fait un
moment que je le dis en plus moi je
crois toujours aux chances d'aronian
c'est mon petit chouchou
je crois en ses chances et ceux qui n'a
pas la troisième partie d'affilée on
l'espère et après trois défaites
d'affilée il va commencer à se poser des
questions il va commencer un peu à
douter de ses capacités et franchement
j'aurais pu laisser la deuxième vidéo
j'aurais pu laisser mais je suis pas sûr
que
aime ça on va on va regarder celle-là
je sais pas s'il y a des coups
intéressants et avec la jambe en coup
E6 aussi une menace qui peut être sympa
sondage en cours
non mais pour le coup pour le coup je
refuse
je refuse ton sondage je suis désolé
c'est même pas moi c'est que là pour le
coup
pour le coup
[Musique]
c'est pas grave
je vous la montre je suis bien gentil
là je suis créatif mais non
tu vas pas en compte les règles quand
même là je vais me faire taper sur les
doigts à partir comme c'est pas bien
à la base c'est l'idée c'est comme
d'avoir la caméra sur les joueurs et pas
non la dame non non non non
c'était complètement gagnant incroyable
incroyable c'est la pause ouais bon ok
c'était la remontada j'y croyais
il est blasé
il est blasé et à la place de Tours
c'était quand même la torture pour les
noirs de position
c'était la tortue
dur dur dur pour pour les bonnes
s'incline
dans cette partie alors qu'il avait mené
et maintenant on va reparti avec moi à 6
et maintenant j'y crois plus trop
là elle aurait pu être à moins 4
et
c'est toujours moins sympa en fait
non
ouais mais en vrai c'est
moins 4 avec un corps d'humeur de match
bon
tu vois tu peux commencer le bulle avec
moi 3 par exemple
[Musique]
ça joue là moi si ça fait beaucoup trop
et en plus chaque partie ça dure ça dure
environ 7 minutes
donc là il reste 26 minutes
oui c'est pas fini encore mais bon non
je pense qu'il a je pense qu'il a pas vu
il a oublié hein il a oublié enfin il a
pas vérifié
[Musique]
c'est triste
les gens qui vont venir d'ici quelques
minutes je vais rester avec vous je
ferai la pause
après à la fin du timer jusqu'à la pause
mais difficile
les dames c'est quoi une dame en échec
c'est quoi une dame
comment vas-tu
ouais bah ouais et encore et encore
vintage j'étais là j'étais vraiment
hyper parce que à rognan il était mené
de
7 ans et il vient de gagner deux parties
d'affilée
il a gagné deux parties d'affilée et la
troisième partie il avait il avait une
superposition regarde ce qui vient de
faire
et bon - 4 quand tu gagnes 3 parties
lafilée tu peux un peu faire tester
l'adversaire en plus chaud tu sais que
saut c'est pas le plus confiant des
joueurs
mais bon là ça fait trop loin là ça fait
trop mais en fait en 5 + une il a
vraiment tilté à rognan il y a eu deux
nuls d'affilée de première partie puis
cinq défaites d'affilée pour harmonium
c'était ouais c'est pas un bon match en
tout cas il va bien et
là en blitz ça allait beaucoup mieux
parce que dans tous les petits qu'il a
fait il avait l'avantage autant il
allait vite c'était bien mais
ok pour voir un peu ce qui se passe dans
la deuxième partie du Blitz faut
vraiment qu'il arrive à engranger le
maximum de points là essayer de finir au
moins à moins 4 ça serait déjà une belle
réussite pour apprendre en Bullet en
Bullet tout est possible
donc essayer de revenir
plus possible en tout cas franchement
dans les trois plus simples en termes de
niveau de jeu à rognan il est beaucoup
plus fort que soit autant en 5 muffins
c'était franchement pas terrible mais en
3 + 1 il a montré quand même de très
belles choses et il peut je pense venir
sur une bonne note en 3 + 5 pour
engager les bullets avec un score
peut-être moindre et essayer de remonter
un peu tout ça mais ok là maintenant les
la côte pour harmonian elle est devenue
extrêmement élevé mais vous savez que je
fais l'optimiste et j'y crois toujours
chacun son tour Cécile là aujourd'hui
c'est c'est
rognan après il y a tous les jours et un
peu des matchs je crois que nous avec
cheeseca on va pas tout couvrir je crois
on va couvrir les matchs les plus les
plus intéressants donc par exemple on a
on va avoir demain il y a Sarana Sarine
qui a pas de couvert
le 8 on va avoir à l'IRESA
contre entre King qui sera couvert la 19
heures par Kevin bandit
après on va avoir le 11 mvl Google qui
sera bien sûr couvert par par Kevin
Bordy à partir de 14h30 et puis à 19h il
y aura le match de
11 et sera moi qui vais le couvrir ce
match là
et après on verra après on s'est même
pas encore plus compliqué donc il y a
pas encore de date mais en tout cas on
verra tous ces petits matchs là mais un
bon programme aussi ouais un bon
programme il y a plein de matchs je vous
montre un petit peu pour ceux qui l'ont
pas vu pour ceux qui l'auraient raté le
petit bracket qui est ici
avec les matchs donc on a carvana Abdou
Sarine Sarana
mvl Google
[Musique]
et le match concombre en ce moment saut
à Ronal donc tous les matchs de Richie
après il y aura les Carles et demi la
finale et tout la majorité en tout cas
sera couvert par cheesecom Fr
alors je vais revenir sur
sur le truc donc c'est un qui aura les
noirs
hop là les joueurs qui sont installés et
qui vont reprendre d'ici quelques
minutes je pense
on a quand même VL et certaines filles
françaises c'est un peu le rêve
comment les gens ont sélectionné
je pense alors je sais pas comment sont
sélectionnés peut-être trouver inside le
sait j'imagine que certains sont
sélectionnés par la performance qu'ils
ont fait dans l'ancien
speechestre par le hello tu as les
joueurs attractifs du circuit comme bon
mvl
firu
quinzaine sauna CAF tous ces gens-là ont
vraiment les voir dans le circuit Ding
champion du monde maintenant il va aussi
être invité je sais pas comment ils sont
choisis mais en tout cas je pense que
l'orga
l'orga invite les joueurs
qu'il veut voir jouer quoi c'est son
tournoi c'est lui qui décide
quatre joueurs sortis des qualifications
ok ça fait 6
ça fait 6 déjà et après le reste
la disque qui sont invités mais bon
invités mais tu invites vraiment les
joueurs qui sont les plus sympas à
regarder quoi tu habitais vraiment les
joueurs j'ai pas invités
les joueurs qui
qui ont plaisir à regarder
merci Robin
c'est une
une comment c'est pas l'ouverture déjà
[Musique]
c'est pas écrit là un petit gorina
mais pour jouer
une ouverture qui de nos jours n'est
quasiment plus joué d'ailleurs même au
niveau plus du tout jouer du tout
donc
c'est parti un peu bizarre un peu
comment à rognan arrive à surprendre
dans cette ouverture donc Robin c'est
Robin des bouquins c'est oui c'est un
miroba c'est ça c'est lui
l'unique
c'est rose qu'il a joué ouais en fait
mon rosé
c'était vraiment le joueur qui qui
jouait tous les trucs surprenants
créatif
incroyable ce gros zavitch c'est
jusqu'à ce qu'il ait refusé de prendre
une photo avec moi
je l'ai vu à un tournoi war je vais
demander si pour prendre une photo il
m'a dit yes et il est parti
j'ai pas compris
et du coup et depuis je me suis dit bon
pas très sympa en fait
pas très sympa à se relever
mais ouais c'était mon vraiment mon
idole
j'aurais bien aimé prendre une photo
avec lui il m'a dit oui et il est parti
c'est bizarre
quand mais du roi voyage
en fait tout ce qui existe comme dans
lui il a tout fait
ouais j'ai refusé c'est ça
c'était à l'époque du je sais pas pour
ceux qui ont connu le
tournoi c'était quelquefois c'était le
Amber le mélodie Amber qui se jouait à
des fois à Cannes et à Nice et à Monaco
de base plutôt à Monaco et après il a
été admise parce qu'il y a un problème
d'hôtel
un tournoi qui se jouait avec des
parties rapides et des parties à
l'aveugle ça se joue à Nice et moi comme
j'habite à Nice et ben je vais tous les
jours là-bas il y avait des salles
spectateurs il était tous les jours à
regarder les
regarder les joueurs j'étais comme un
hashtag comme un gosse quoi trop content
trop content en tout cas et
[Musique]
et j'avais le bac au même moment j'avais
bâclé mon mon
bac blanc pour venir voir carte SCÈNE
j'avais mon prof d'anglais l'épreuve
d'anglais qui a duré 2h quoi je t'avais
en deux minutes pour aller voir 45
j'ai pas une mauvaise en plus j'avais eu
peut-être eu un 14 sur 20 ou 15 sur 20
en une demi-heure c'était quand même
plutôt plutôt une bonne une bonne note
on va rester sur constance et bon c'est
bac blanc en foutait
mais voilà ça c'est ma vie je pense que
tu es aussi mais mais
ça reste quand des bonnes anecdotes j'ai
vu tous les joueurs j'avais
17 ans c'est comme ça et j'ai connu tous
les joueurs il y avait il y avait il y
avait il y avait quinzaine qui joue tout
le temps il y avait les Raja bovakin tu
avais un Andre tu avais cramique tu
avais chinois
[Musique]
bref génial quand tu peux aller voir un
tournoi et franchement voir le tournoi
en vrai pour voir les joueurs en vrai
c'est trop cool quoi c'est vraiment
en classique plus fort que j'ai joué
pas énorme
pas énorme je crois que c'est le grand
frais
non c'est pas qu'on va faire
que le renforcer je pense
malheureusement j'ai jamais joué de
joueurs à 2007 en partie je crois
que je fais une Bacro plein de fois mais
en rapide je l'ai joué 4 ou 5 fois je
pense Étienne
et en blitz
et en partie lente je n'ai jamais
vraiment oui c'est très fort Laurent
je crois pas
ça va faire nul allez ça répète
et je crois que ça y est je crois que
araignée
je crois que c'est je crois que c'est
terminé
[Musique]
il y a plus de temps
il y a plus de temps et en face qui qui
est toujours solide quoi il se laisse
pas il se laisse pas avoir
et un Andrew j'ai failli jouer
à Nantes je crois que c'était avant la
partie
avant la partie que j'ai perdu pour
devenir maître vous savez être 1600 et
bah avant cette partie
je pense la partie contrat d'Inde enfin
que j'aurais dû jouer c'était mon pire
souvenir et chacun j'ai eu le plus gros
bad bit toute ma vie c'était encore
Sébastien
dans les beaux théâtres
j'ai eu le plus gros baby de toute ma
vie
en tant que joueur d'échec c'était un
truc de fou j'avais fait un super
tournoi c'est un tournoi rapide de 15 +
5 comme ça j'ai battu deux grands
maîtres à 25,50
donc j'avais un super départage et puis
au final dernière ronde je joue
qualifier parce qu'en fait vous savez il
y avait deux jours qualifiés il y avait
un an et oui enfin je crois un truc
comme ça qui était qui était venu pour
jouer contre les autres et tu avais
genre
[Musique]
tu avais 14 joueurs les 14 premiers
tournois qui se qualifiait 14 + 2 16
pour jouer les saisons de finale
et du coup ça huitième du coup et du
coup
[Musique]
il faut sept points pour se qualifier
dans les 14 premiers et j'ai 6 sur 8 et
je joue contre le joueur le moins fort
que je puisse jouer j'ai joué un maître
international 2400 et l'autre donc
j'étais content parce que parce que à
part lui c'était 2006 2007 quoi et donc
j'ai beaucoup de chance je contre lui et
le mec de 1400 il est encore plus de
chance parce que moi
et j'ai joué une des parties les plus
importantes de ma vie
et c'était du 3 + 2 ce que j'avais fait
ouais c'est comme ça ou non non
c'était du 15 + quelque chose toujours
j'ai une position complètement gagnante
j'avais trois plans de plus 4 points de
plus complètement gagnante et je demande
un coup voilà il a attaqué
et le pire c'est que malgré ça et ben
j'ai failli pas perdre tellement j'avais
une position écrasante mais bon qui est
une dame c'est une dame quoi et en
perdant la partie et ben j'ai perdu bon
de l'argent parce qu'il y avait un gros
bruit à la win mais surtout
surtout si je gagnais et ben j'étais le
plus mauvais élo des qualifié et donc
c'était sûr que je que je jouais contre
un an de aller-retour sur la scène la
grande scène étape de Bastia je jouais
contre un ande blanc noir avec tous les
joueurs à 2700 aller backy les fraises
ça aurait été c'est le rêve quoi et le
pire c'est que deux jours avant le
tournoi j'ai rêvé que le jouet à vendre
sur la scène j'ai rêvé que je joue à
lande et là quand je joue la partie
c'était complètement gagnant contre le
MI et en fait c'est bon mon rêve qui se
réalise c'était fou quoi et j'ai demandé
un coup et là j'ai envie de pleurer j'ai
vraiment envie de
trop bad bits parce que tu joues un
monde pour moi c'était l'horaire en fait
c'est même pas l'argent que j'ai perdu
parce que bon c'est même pas
pour moi c'était vraiment jouable
[Musique]
un Russe
et du coup j'étais assis du coup dans le
dans le théâtre de Bastia à regarder mon
adversaire se faire massacrer contre un
homme j'étais content
je la regarde il s'est pris 15 coups 15
coups mais j'aurais fait pareil j'aurais
perdu aussi hein c'est pas le problème
mais juste le fait tu joues un ande tu
sais c'est la classe quoi ça prend la
classe quoi
c'était la classe
mais bon
[Musique]
l'enjeu oui l'enjeu
ma bloquer c'est sûr les émotions
j'étais tellement gagnant et après je me
souviens romain Édouard parce qu'à la
fin je crois que ma partie
tout gagner quoi bref c'est la vie c'est
le sport
ok donc d'un projet 6 donc il va revenir
en Détroit peut-être un jour
c'est comme
1600 alors que j'étais à un point de
j'étais à un point de passer maître
international et 600
mentalement il est pas là mentalement et
comme des choses à régler mais bon
après le tour était plus fort contre les
les
contre les bons genres d'échec des gens
moins fort je tendance à
moins bien jouer mais bon ça c'est un
défaut aussi que j'ai un c'est pas bien
oui maintenant j'ai mon titre
heureusement maintenant j'en parle j'en
parlerai voilà
ça a l'air chaud là pour Carver les
prendre des cinq avec une petite
découverte et harmoniale qui gagne cette
partie est-ce qu'on y croit encore
est-ce qu'on y croit encore il a moins 5
est-ce qu'on y croit encore
l'après dit ah tu veux
alors on en a reparlé ça me paraissait
normal
vu tout ce que je faisais
j'avais mis en place un stream d'un qui
était chargé de faire des commentaires
et tout
franchement
il a fait par le score
il a 4
donc oui bon bah j'étais un peu dire
compromis avec cet événement qu'on
devait stream qu'on devait jouer etc
c'était normal de faire une vidéo dessus
pour expliquer ce qui s'était passé
et bon et puis même moi ça m'a permis
aussi de passer
de passer un peu
de surmonter on va dire cet épisode je
pense le fait vraiment de
d'avoir fait la vidéo ça m'a aidé perso
donc
ok prise
les belles émotions
je sais pas
je pense j'ai plus de cauchemars que de
rêve
moi j'ai plein de parties qui est
importantes qui étaient sympas et
c'était pourtant et tout mais
[Musique]
je me casse par offre je pense l'argent
sur internet je suis sûr que c'est pas
grave
4 fois le vrai casse pas
sur internet il y a très longtemps
sinon j'ai pas de de
ça comme tout le monde
peut-être mon premier grand maître
j'ai fait une très belle partie contre
le premier point j'ai battu j'avais 2100
vélo j'ai fait une combinaison très
jolie peut-être que
peut-être que c'est
ma meilleure souvenir et chacun c'est
quand tu bats un grand mec quand tu as
2100 et l'autre c'est bon
[Musique]
et sinon non j'ai pas tout le temps de
grand maître à 2006 2005
mais rien de spécial
[Musique]
des bons tournois les belles des belles
perfs mais bon
pas tant que ça quoi
je pense qu'on se souvient plus des des
mauvais épisode ou des bons
je pense que
les mots et bizarre j'en ai plein des
bons je vais en avoir aussi plein mais
là actuellement
j'ai plus de mal à m'en souvenir
contrairement à bien sûr
mais je pense qu'on a plus de mal à s'en
souvenir
on aime bien râler moi en France on aime
bien on aime bien se plaindre vous savez
quand même
la foule
F4 il va y avoir il va y avoir 5
il y a un sacré qui a été
OK
il faut la prendre là
plus triste que tu n'aies joyeux quand
tu gagnes autant
ouais je pense non
en fait
je pense que quand tu perds quelque
chose et que tu es triste que tu as eu
des grosses attentes
alors que quand tu gagnes un truc de
base tu as pas forcément la tente de
gagner ça donc tu as moins ce côté je
sais pas je suis pas psy je suis pas
tout ça mais j'imagine que il y a un
côté
attendre aussi je pense par rapport à
tout ça
un ami qui était un ami nous a quitté le
discours que toi il avait pourtant les
auteurs
il va y avoir trop bien je pense
cavalier 5 a été joué pourquoi il a pas
récupéré le cavalier
je comprends pas j'ai un épisode là les
gars
je suis fou ou pourquoi il a pas besoin
de cavalier ah il y avait G5 ok ok
peut-être que j'ai raté un truc tactique
ok la pièce était perdue quand il est
arrivé
fougère
mais au final vous savez que le type de
et ce n'est pas fait
ça m'a rien fait en fait
c'est comme si je l'attendais comme si
je savais en fait c'est bizarre c'est
bizarre de dire ça alors qu'on a perdu
contre un 1600 quand il fallait gagner
mais au final en fait
j'ai l'impression que ça m'a pas fait
grand chose c'est comme si je savais
pour moi c'est
c'est normal c'est comme si je
l'attendais quoi c'est comme si j'avais
toujours su
exactement ça
et ouais pendant que je sais on en a
déjà parlé mais
en fait c'est pas c'est bon c'est quand
même longtemps que j'avais quand même je
pense à un niveau de passer maître donc
c'est un peu plus une
soulagement qu'autre chose on le sait au
final
c'est pas un hasard quand même
et tout ça à un moment donné
mais c'est vrai que bon on se pose des
questions on se dit bon ce qu'on va y
arriver ou pas
est-ce que je peux te mater ça serait
beau ça marchera pas cavaler ici sa
tension attention
qui va venir ranger 7 et manger le
cavalier là c'est vraiment terminé de se
terminer on a un rognan ne reviendra
jamais au score
c'est fichu
c'est la dernière partie des blinks
normalement
le 5 c'est toi théorique
de jouer
après il a moins 6 encore
le titre
en fait moi je suis maître
enfin je suis pas non plus
je suis pas un grand joueur quoi faites
ce que je veux dire c'est que
mettre c'est pas un grand c'est pas
quelque chose d'énorme en fait dans la
vie
que moi ça change pas tant ma vie que ça
au final faire un tournoi oui en fait
quand je fais un tournoi j'aurais plus
de conditions
ça veut dire que par exemple vous savez
il y a des gens qui sont invités dans
plein de tournoi ça va dire que pour
jouer ils ont des conditions comme des
hébergements gratuits ou comme des trucs
qui sont payés bah juste en fait le
simple fait d'être
maître ça te donne des possibilités un
peu de conditions donc ça te fait gagner
un petit peu on va dire voilà après
longtemps tournoi
j'ai tout pareil que quand j'étais ma
profil en fait le TT j'avais déjà avant
une petite émettre ça
quelles invitations il y a plein de
trucs c'est vrai que en tant que maître
international quand je fais un tournoi
ben je vais pouvoir
être un peu mieux quand je suis maître
fille
en France en tout cas tu as jamais rien
de nulle part tu as rien du tout
inscription et tu payes tout quand t'es
maître bon bah tout est gratuit et en
plus dans un tournoi tu peux avoir des
conditions donc soit des aides pour le
transport soit tu peux avoir un
hébergement gratuit soit tu peux avoir
plein de choses comme ça ça dépend un
peu du tournoi et de ce qui propose à
l'étranger c'est différent en tout cas
en Espagne
en tant que maître feed j'ai souvent eu
des conditions
mais bon
c'est vrai que ça mais après à part ça à
part ça
il y a pas plus de tournois que qu'avant
pour la genre titré tycles
c'est genre titre et un toit qui se joue
tous les mardis soir
oui parfois quand mettre fuite t'as des
aides à 50% des fois c'est gratuit mais
rarement généralement tu payes quand
même généralement tu payes par contre
quand t'es mettre international tu as
plus le droit de faire payer les joueurs
c'est interdit sauf les tournois rapide
des Blitz c'est l'orga qui choisit par
contre les
Open en partie vente qui sont
homologuées Fides n'ont pas le droit de
faire payer un mètre c'est interdit
c'est comme ça
ça fait tous les règles
donc
c'est dur ici mais toujours un petit
pion de plus pour
pour
4 6 fous des seins que 6 x 4 et essayez
d'entrer à tour ici le pion avance sera
plus le fou qui pourra contrôler la case
peut-être c'est la meilleure chance
pratique de
[Musique]
Levon parce que les trois il y a quand
même on reprend il est impossible
toujours fourchette mais ça traîne par
exemple la sur un point il
reprend la tête c'était possible
c'est ouvert au CM ONM
donc cm c'est quand il va mettre et même
c'est
mettre national qui n'existe pas en
France
tu as le CM quand diamètre
mais bon je vois pas trop l'intérêt mais
il en sait à
il attend pour passer en CM2
l'année prochaine
si les sages
il est encore tout petit
ça va venir ça va venir
[Musique]
oui
ils sont
vachement couverts par des streams moi
je l'ai vu tout à l'heure je l'ai joué
ça faisait
[Musique]
très longtemps que l'iPad joué
j'aime pas il y a plein de raisons pour
lesquelles je n'aime pas mais la plus
grosse raison c'est que toutes les
parties volantes ça j'aime pas avoir des
parties dans la base
gratuite
du coup je joue plus ça m'intéresse pas
oui oui mais en fait je pense que le
titre de mi est par rapport de maître
fit par rapport pour moi par exemple
c'est plus pour moi-même en fait je me
sens mieux enfin c'est juste une gloire
que j'ai réussi personnellement c'est
pour ça que je suis content mais après
ça change pas grand chose en même temps
noir moi ça change pas ma vie c'est
pareil en fait d'être fait doute
peut-être mettre international mais
c'est que sur le papier c'est mieux
c'est plus sympa
et
voilà mais sinon il y a pas il y a pas
beaucoup de différences qui prend ces
quatre
manger des cèpes peut-être avec mon four
moi
ça ça
Marius qui est l'art de connaitre
en FM1
toi aussi ça ok ça commence à avoir une
belle tête histoire qui peut tomber
et là le pion qui va tomber en B7 quand
tu prends ça tu prends un 6 derrière
ou bas s'il prend qui prend ici je crois
qu'il est coupé il y a un pion plus ça
peut être gagnant pour
pour Harmonia cette histoire
ça dans la partie du tournoi enfin du de
la section de la section 3 + 1
si il arrive à gagner la partie il
serait plus que moins 5 ce qui est
beaucoup mais après en Bullet ça reste
toujours rattrapable
pour prendre le 4
il adore
encore démontré aujourd'hui quelle
classe et abandon perdu autant pour
Wesley ben écoutez du coup maintenant la
partie qui va commencer qui ne marche
pas non ça va s'arrêter ça va s'arrêter
tu le savais parce que le temps est
arrivé à zéro donc
et ici il y a un petit -5 pour aronyan
donc il va falloir en 30 minutes de
Bullet
faire un très très grosse score pour
revenir à hauteur de westlesso et c'est
d'accrocher au moins un département
et on revient pour le dénouement de ce
match en Bullet une plus une là ça va
être sympa ça va être sympa
ce petit Bullet pour terminer je vous
dis à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les title Tuss
day.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chains.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
je suis de retour avec vous
et ça va reprendre dans quelques
instants
[Musique]
de voir comment ça se passe donc je vous
rappelle le score le score plus plus 5
par rapport à ce Wesley et ils vont
entamer les bullettes donc une plus donc
c'est du Bullet mais c'est pas vraiment
du vrai Bullet en une plus zéro vous
savez il y a quand même du temps il y a
un incrément entre toutes les parties
d'une seconde donc ça va quand même vite
et il y a quand même du temps pour
réfléchir un peu c'est pas tout à fait
quand même du vrai vrai Bullet
[Musique]
ah oui non mais c'est très long c'est
clair franchement un rognan s'il gagne
ce match ce serait vraiment la classe
perdre 7 1 et remonter bon il y a très
peu de chance mais parce que oui c'est
un très bon genre de Bullet
mais sosley c'est pas un manche non plus
mais en fait il faut qu'il lui en mette
peut-être trois quoi il en met trois
et après il fait quoi
tu lui en mets trois tu commences à
avoir un peu peur franchement
ok je pense que il est vraiment pas
favori mais si jamais il commence à
prendre quelques unes au début il y a
peut-être un moyen qu'il arrive à
monter ça mais bon il est vrai qu'il y a
quand même un peu de peu de chance quoi
c'est c'est
[Musique]
pas clair cette histoire
c'est pas clair du tout cette histoire
OK et c'est parti allez hop
c'est lancé
c'est lancé il y en a ici
stocker les blancs première partie pour
démarrer cette portion de 30 minutes
allez il faut jouer cavalier F3 ça a été
joué
donc là ça va très vite ça va très très
vite et on est tous derrière
l'arrière armoniale
tamisée ou pas à t'amuser dommage
j'aurais bien aimé j'aurais bien aimé
j'aurais mis l'inverse c'est pas grave
t'inquiète pas c'est pas grave et même
le seul à avoir parié sur sursaut donc
je te félicite bravo tu as mis 10k sur
ce d'avoir parlé sur Spotify
tu es tout seul au monde est-ce que vous
voulez combattre
parce que du coup
pas trop intérêt quoi
alors cavalier B3 allez part sur une sur
une faute apparemment qu'avec G4 mais
fin la partie et oui ça a été joué ça a
été un jeu par notre ami Aronian qui va
commencer regardez regardez le temps 29
secondes contre 55 secondes pour un
rognan c'est pas une première
démonstration
le pion qui va tomber avec un pion passé
ça va être très difficile
et le fou qui se fait enfermé
malheureusement
il a fauté juste derrière
parce que
marlou IVC récupérer comme ça
alors
pas mal aussi attention ce cavalier qui
est à moitié
en danger quand même
bouger cavalier 2 ça marche
avec monstrueux et la prise et rien qui
est là allez tours qui passe en 8 on
passe par là
je le sens bien à Rognac dans ce match
aller tour à deux ça va être abondant
pour cette première petite bullette et
je l'avais dit des gars j'avais dit ou
pas
est-ce que je l'avais dit
c'est la remontada pour rogner allez 1-0
je l'avais dit de toute façon
le début je le dis
il y a un écho de fou en tout cas chez
moi enfin moi je m'entends pas mais
est-ce qu'il y a un écho est-ce que
c'est que une carte qui a un problème
moi j'ai rien touché depuis tout à
l'heure
je n'ai rien touché
allez
je crois que c'est un problème chez toi
j'ai eu ton message privé je te
répondrai pas
ah oui non c'est ce serait pas
regardable car
si j'étais un mode cathédrale
ça c'est un peu compliqué
10 secondes dans la pendule d'avance
avec
il faut que je vide
qui qui a pas compris qu'on avait changé
de cadence qui continue à être lent
allez il faut jouer là qui arrive
attention un peu
oui c'est le coup bien évidemment
ça après on pourra pousser les pions à
3,4 peut-être oui veux tous mes coups
Ariane il a tout compris
si je me mets à la place d'aronia les
gars on va gagner c'est sûr
je me mets la loi sa place cavalier C4
c'est parti et oui bien évidemment allez
est-ce que toi là encore mieux avec les
comme ça quel Seigneur
grande classe qui va venir après en D2
4 c'est pas mal
j'aurais pas joué
autant la jauge elle est complètement
folle vous inquiétez pas des fois elle
bug là il faut le bug
alors comment on arrive à mettre cavaler
la peut-être ça peut être pas mal
cavalier
entre temps
qui va venir en C5 peut-être
soyez comme moi la chose de la reconnu
c'est moi qui jouait n'est pas d'accord
du tout attention au max attention à ça
ou à ça
[Musique]
il s'est mis dans la salle de
à chaque fois
allez faut continuer à jouer vite on
peut encore rattraper
mais vous avez un Bullet qui a eu que
deux parties il y a déjà 6 minutes qui
sont qui sont écoulés
donc ça il y a pas beaucoup beaucoup de
parties non plus ça va vite
ma mère
il faut jouer vite en plus et rien il
sait qu'il doit jouer vite pour attraper
le temps il sait que
qu'il faut qu'il joue vite qui prennent
tous les risques donc en fait bon ben il
en Austin quoi
pas facile
il y a quand même un bel avantage le
temps normalement bon
normalement il y a pas trop de soucis
allez il y a plein de pièces qui sont
échangées c'est proprement
cavalier E5 je peux pas le faire
c'est ta pleutre
[Musique]
c'est un solide agressif
j'aime bien et oui là je m'en fous avec
attention à la tour là c'est encore
bugger ma joie
et donc ils sont forts
[Musique]
allez il faut la gagner celle-là et vite
vite
après je sais que
saut il est du style à s'arrêter de
jouer pour gagner du temps à la pendule
il est des gens comme ça il y en a qui
sont comme ça d'autres qui sont pas
comme ça je sais que mvl est pas comme
ça je sais qu'il y a plein de gens qui
sont pas comme ça mais fait partie de
cette petite
minorité de joueurs comme comme
tous ces gens là
et là c'est juste perdu à 36 pièces de
moins mais tu continues encore longtemps
parce que pour la gagner il va mettre du
temps et que comme ça met du temps pour
la gagner et ben il va faire exprès de
faire durer la partie au maximum pour
que le temps s'écoule et que
n'est pas le temps de la finir
proprement
cette bonne bière oui mais il y a des
gens qui ne font pas du tout donc
allez next
elle est Huit et demi ça fait moins 4
parties
en 20 minutes tu peux le faire
tu peux le faire le bon moi j'y crois
il faut que je vide là
4 à 4
petits Rogue
enfin
pas de
[Musique]
ça reste pas encore terminé ce match
faut gagner celle-là
la prochaine faire douter sa
il faut le faire douter
j'aime bien les blancs ici
qui bug tout le temps
qu'un jour décape ça va être un coup ça
risque d'être un coup un jour
en préparant je sais pas dans quel sens
mais
allait être un sacrifice un jour sur H6
qui avait le 3
ouais n'a qu'à il fait son son
ça marche pas on sait tous on le connaît
c'est une crapule
H4 cavalier F5 mais il le sait que c'est
une crapule c'est encore une fois cette
bonne guerre
très très jolie de la part de
en plus les pions
ici mais c'est pas grave on a les
colonnes
allez courage 4 on prime
attention
[Musique]
j'aime pas
les vis-à-vis
pas bien les vis-à-vis des bonnes
tours on mange de quoi là du pion
il y a des cartes qui va avancer on va
ouvrir la position
6 peut-être et qu'elle avait des quatre
peut-être c'est une bonne tour on va
plonger 3 c'est difficile de faire aussi
[Musique]
allez il faut jouer
encore plus fort
c'est dur quand même ici pour pour les
voir dans les pas bien
allez ranger 2 8
c'est quoi la menace c'est pas
cool des petits coups
[Musique]
oui aussi
peut-être
tombe
[Musique]
il y a rien là où il a tout
ça va trop vite
pas loin de tomber ce petit saut
c'est fini malheureusement c'est terminé
perdre autant quel dommage quel dommage
cette partie
quel dommage
en fin de partie il y a plein d'erreurs
mais c'est normal les gens ont plus de
temps il y a une grosse pression
et s'il avait gagné la partie un peu ça
revient à toujours un petit vous savez
un petit doute quoi
un petit doute quoi mais bon
ce qui fait que de déconner
pas du tout
C3 donc là il y avait quoi tout à
l'heure c'est quoi la ligne
je crois qu'il change chaque fois dans
cette ligne
plein de parties
dans les carreaux c'est autre chose
Bullet en bulleticaru
c'est autre chose clairement autre chose
mais bon ok il y a un problème sur F7 ça
peut faire ça peut faire mal en drive
mais attention aux quatre peurs
qui peut intéressante ok pour cette
[Musique]
après après là pour moi le Bullet c'est
pas du calcul c'est plus de l'instant
que du calcul c'est pas du calcul pur
calcule pur je pense qu'elle VL il est
pas mort que d'accord on voit qu'elle
par contre
ambulette
[Musique]
c'est hallucinant quand même mais c'est
pas du calcul pour moi le Bullet c'est
tout des réflexes et du et
surtout
comment dire
oui c'est des réflexes quoi
la tête quoi c'est pas vraiment des
échecs dans le sens où il y a pas de
calcul il y a pas vraiment de
la stratégie il y a pas plus comme ça
mais
c'est plus de l'instinct quoi l'instant
c'est hyper important en Bullet
qui est des deux
après
le calcul mais au-delà de ça
aussi beaucoup
bonne nuit à toi merci d'avoir cette
jusqu'à cette heure là
de base il a toujours été ça a toujours
été un excellent joueur de de Blitz
Bullet toute sa vie
toute sa vie ça a été un excellent genre
donc bon
what is this
complètement craqué
c'est pas fini encore des villes ton
Condes 5
et soit tu as failli perdre autant et
qui perd autant incroyablement dans
cette partie Aronian qui gagne
aller à il reste 12 minutes là c'est
maintenant là il faut tout gagner
là il faut tout gagner 4 parties en 12
minutes je pense c'est faisable
je pense c'est faisable
[Musique]
ouais moi je me souviens à l'époque même
sur c'était je sais plus quel âge mais
sur PLAY chest il avait 3500 euros il
mettait des 10 € à tout le monde
complètement
il y a toujours été
toute sa vie il a été un des meilleurs
joueurs online
alors que le chèque c'était pas un bon
était très fort mais ça pourrait pas du
tout
alors moi j'étais pas de Icc
malheureusement ça peut être pour moi
c'était trop jeune à cette époque là
j'étais pas encore sur internet
je suis arrivé un peu après enfin je
suis arrivé pendant le boulot nécessaire
mais j'étais pas trop sur internet à
l'époque et j'étais plus sur Playstation
une très bonne partie mais regardez il a
20 secondes d'avance autant et ça bah au
final ça peut
ça peut faire quelque chose
parce que regarder
[Musique]
ceux qui paniquent un petit peu au temps
ça pourrait vraiment sympa sur le plan
F7
je n'aime pas hyper ici avec B4 qui va
arriver on sent peut-être encore une
victoire peut-être
d'Armagnac qui pourrait être à -3
peut-être dans ce match
ce sera absolument incroyable qu'il
arrive à remonter tout ça les bonnes
après cette ce début en 5 + 1 qui était
vraiment laborieux s'il arrive à se
faire ce serait vraiment un truc de ouf
mais il faut il faut jouer vite il faut
marquer des points
et merci beaucoup pour le raid le
réveilleur merci beaucoup
tu m'as réveillé d'ailleurs
merci beaucoup c'est pas possible c'est
bien passé un petit saut
un petit saut pour toi mais je suis
quand même plus pour un rien que pour ça
et c'est moi ton prochain avec damaka
[Musique]
et Matt incroyable arrogant qui revient
un petit peu au score ici allez juste le
score plus -3 alors je sais que c'est
encore beaucoup
je sais que c'est encore beaucoup
en fait il faut que je regarde deux
avec 10 minutes il faut qu'il en gagne 2
et qui commence la troisième partie qui
se terminera assez froid
c'est la bonne ligne
mais bon ok on est pour les vannes donc
mais F3 à 3 c'est le meilleur coup
monsieur saut je connais mieux que vous
cette ligne
allez
les points de scène ça sert à rien
c'est
[Musique]
c'est des points virtuels que tu peux
parier quand on fait des trucs
[Musique]
allez en tout cas il faut marquer des
points là la jauge qui est complètement
cassée
alors je vois actif
taxi là il peut vraiment faire douter à
son gamin s'il gagne celle-là il va
vraiment le faire douter
les s'inquiéter
ça peut être
prends un F6 prise je prends B2 toujours
le plus emprise je vous dis n'importe
quoi tout à l'heure tout à l'heure
il faut jouer là allez
je suis d'accord aussi
je suis d'accord aussi jour ou quoi
allez
qu'est-ce qui se passe
non il a la petite en fait hein
[Musique]
c'est un peu chaud cette histoire là il
vient de passer 40 secondes sur un coup
ouais
le réveil
un tout petit peu avant peut-être pour
réveiller notre ami rognan
merci en tout cas pour le reste merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
allez faut essayer de vite venir gagner
ce pion
17 dures empêcher quand même
ouais ça va peut-être faire nul mais bon
nul c'est quand même une bonne opération
pour Wesley
parce que ça fait une partie de moins de
jouer
ça c'est le meilleur plan ça sent
la main si tu prends j'ai échec
[Musique]
ok il prend sa chance en tout cas
il prend sa chance
voilà
c'est très compliqué ça va perdre ici
cette partie ça va perdre et les veines
qui devraient abandonner
pour gagner du temps pour se refaire
dans une autre partie les vannes qui
devraient abandonner
en fait clairement pour le match
aller
ouais
[Musique]
le temps il arrive à zéro vraiment
j'ai l'impression qu'il manque qui
restait encore quand même du temps
restait quasiment 10 minutes
avant que ça passe assez vite j'ai pas
fait gaffe
peut-être que je suis fou en fait
ok bon bah du coup ça va partir alors si
j'ai bien compris
c'est un peu que tu penses je sais plus
combien de temps il restait il me
semblait que il me semblait que
[Musique]
c'est le cas c'est terminé
mais du coup il se passe quoi on va voir
on va voir en tout cas
on va voir
ce qu'elle m'a dit
complètement aussi
5 6 c'est dur ouais ça fait 4 points
ouais c'est là normalement il peut en
faire que deux quoi
avec 5-6 minutes il peut en faire que
deux à moins qu'il y a une salade
directe
là c'est gagnant la gagne une pièce
le problème c'est que
c'est que aronia il va pas du tout enfin
c'est que ça va pas abandonner
pour gagner du temps
mais s'il avait trois points à récupérer
en 6 minutes
ça peut éventuellement gagner deux et
lancer vite la troisième ouais c'est dur
il faut il faut se faire à l'idée que
que
c'est fini
c'est clair que c'est fini mais en plus
à chaque fois il va se laisser tomber
il va il va vraiment
[Musique]
ça va pas
de la pendule
[Musique]
il le sait en plus
il le sait bien
en plus
et ouais
[Musique]
franchement
à revenir il était là parce qu'il a
quand même gagné si vous voulez un peu
les deux sept derniers 5 4 et la 5 3
c'est dommage c'est ma prochaine
et il va sur tomber
allez
j'espère que maintenant il reste je sais
pas ça a buggé
c'est le match des Arabes
ils ont du mat tour et cavalier
en fait il faut qu'il en commence deux
il faut qu'il en commence de
peut-être il va venir celle-là et
peut-être encore une chance faire une
dernière mais bon
il attend en fait il joue plus échecs
solide et l'objectif c'est que la partie
elle dure très longtemps vous voyez elle
est plutôt solide et il va attendre
les pièces
c'est bien aussi
les rois quelque part
et nuls voilà bon c'est terminé
c'est nul
au final de score c'est 15 12 il a
commencé avec avec
le premier set il a réussi quand même
bien remonté
a bien remonter mais malheureusement
c'est pas suffisant
et
quelques en pensez de du même format
mais le faire en forme de 7 par exemple
premier set un peu comme au tennis peu
importe le score 7 1 ok c'est un 7-0
après 4 3 ça fait partout
et faire un truc en avec des sept je
trouve que c'est plus sympa les 7
parce que
c'est un peu d'espoir parce que là ça
joue contre la montre
au final
alors que
le temps il y en a plein
de partir je peux te dire que
viens me chercher
en plus je passe vous avez vu
[Musique]
la Russe c'est
où la Russe qui a un autre nom c'est la
tu perds très vite l'intérêt du match
quand tu es trop mené parce que là par
exemple au bout de 1h de jeu on a eu 7
et demi un demi bah ok en fait c'est
fini quoi déjà mais on va continuer à
jouer une heure et demie alors que le
match est terminé en soi alors que là tu
perds un 7 toujours un peu revenir donc
voilà quoi ou un écart simplement
mais bon
là en fait il y a certains matchs
ou à la fin ça devient vraiment trop
difficile ça devient un peu une
boucherie quoi c'est un peu
c'est un peu un cirque quoi
donc
parce que là je vois le 7
plus 5 ouais plus 6 + 7
et un pion de plus cette position
mais bon je pense après cette partie je
pense ça va terminer
je pense que le temps va se terminer
c'est sûr
c'est même sûr que ça c'est la dernière
partie du match
voilà
mais les joueurs ils savent peut-être
pas que il y a un taille enfin ils
savent pas combien de temps à combien de
temps les timer je sais pas s'ils le
savent ou pas
je suis passé le savent
de toute façon bon par principe
allez
[Musique]
allez c'est terminé les joueurs on a 15
secondes de décalage les joueurs qui
apparemment ont arrêté je crois
et à rognan qui a perdu ce match qui va
s'en vouloir parce que final il perd de
trois points ce match alors tu regardais
si vous regardez le score et ben il a
quand même gagné les deux portions
Blitz et Bullet à rognan mais bon il a
tellement pris de retard dans le premier
il est perdu il a perdu et il était
derrière donc difficile en tout cas de
revenir après un tel écart en 5 + une
mais en tout cas beau match aujourd'hui
donc je sais pas ce que par rapport au
match qui est arrivé
je vous avais dit quoi je vais
revérifier mon truc
vous avez le match oui le match de Ali
resa qui va se jouer le 8 le 8 c'est
vendredi donc ce vendredi
à partir de 19h sur la chaîne de chascom
FR avec blitzrim et ben vous suivrez le
match que Ali resa contre André Kim donc
très très gros match encore à suivre
donc en tout cas merci à tous d'avoir
suivi le stream jusqu'à maintenant et
moi je vous dis bonne nuit à tous et
bon courage demain pour vous lever pour
aller travailler et
à très très bientôt pour ma part avec
vous bonne soirée ciao ciao